This episode of Your Mom's house is
brought to you by Saatva luxury mattress.
The only online mattress company that
provides free delivery set up and mattress
removal.
Christina.
Oh,
gene testing.
Do I have some dates for you?
I've added two very tiny shows in the
u who roam at flappers flip hairs.
Comedy Club in Sperm Bank.
Just to kind of wet.
Might be getting back in the headlining
cause I'm going to start touring in 2019
so in the u room,
come see me.
October 21st it's a Sunday
and then October 28th and
then November 10th in west
Cylo him I'm, I'm assuming that's how
you say. How do you say west Salaam?
Salaam springs in Oklahoma.
Cherokee casino.
No idea. Okay. Uh,
November 24th my first show
in man Diego has sold out.
I've added a 10 o'clock show at the
house of Brews in San Diego and then
December 7th and fill her up.
Delphia first show sold out.
I've added a late show and fill her up.
Delfia and then December 8th next night,
do dark Teddy's late show
added at the Gramercy theater.
Get your tickets at Christina p
online and I'll be announcing 20,
19 dates very soon. Oh Shit. Sell excite.
And thank you for all your submissions
for tour date. A torn names. Yeah. And uh,
and we made a decision, I'll
let you know later. Great.
You Todd Jean. Later this month
I'll be in Fresno and Bakersfield.
Then I head to flo rider.
I'm going to go and do Fort Myers.
Jack me off Phil Orlando and I've got the
Georgia the first weekend of November.
There's um,
there's a few tickets left for a couple
of those shows and then a few are sold
out.
Uh,
and then from there I do my
very exciting week at the uh,
Welmont in Montclair and four shows
at the Merriam and fill her up.
Delphia the late Friday show in Philly
is the one with tickets available if you
haven't gotten tickets yet,
go there. And of course,
all my 2019 dates or the first half
of the year is on sale all at Thomson
[inaudible] dot com slash tour.
Check those out. I started off, uh,
January 5th in San Francisco at
the Mason. That's exciting. Amaze.
Yes.
Or The dudes are.
That's where the dude or Jean,
we have so much to talk about. So much
to talk about. How much to get into gene.
So much to get into.
Gene,
let's do this.
Here we go.
Where is my phone?
Hey,
well we have time.
here it is.
Ah Huh. Take me out
African style. Here we go.
[inaudible]
oh is Randy.
Don't bring anyone in loving.
Well go to your mom's house.
Someone didn't get the right
order there, Huh? Well, you know,
we've been talking about people who are
so rude when they make their phone calls
on speakerphone and public. Probably my
greatest pet peeve, it is mine to only,
I've, I've gotten a new one. I'm going to
tell you about in a minute here. It's a,
it's in my act now. It's
bothering me. It bothers me too.
But it proves,
I think a theory that we might be having,
that people that are doing their phone
calls in public on speakerphone are
either mentally ill or on drugs.
Um, do you know what's funny?
What you haven't seen? Obviously you
don't see these folders, even the files.
Right, right, right. Uh,
one of these clips of this lady
has called drugs or mentally. Yeah,
that's a new game. We're
gonna play on the shot. Yeah.
And I'm gonna have Dr drew come in
and then he's gonna verify from that.
I'm going to put this on the drew list
before we go even further on this.
I want to, don't forget what
your pet peeve is. Yeah. I
want to congratulate my, uh,
friend, uh, last week's
guest finesse Mitchell,
a an alum of the University
of Miami on his teams, nausea,
getting wind this past week. They
at the semen halls. I lost the bet.
So I'm wearing his shirt. I'm
wearing his shirt. Congratulations.
Finesse and congratulations
to the biggest piece of shit.
Fan Base in all of sports. The University
of Miami Hurricanes. Oh, you're, oh,
you're saying the fans or even pos,
they're the worst.
They're such garbage people. Seriously,
I've spent so much time down there.
I used to go to the orange bowl, their
animals to the biggest piece of this.
And now I don't know much about sports,
so I can't really,
but I've heard that Raiders
fans are pieces of shit too.
That probably be a fair thing to say
now I,
but only because their behavior is bad
from, that's what we're talking about.
Yeah. Okay. Well here's
the thing too about,
because I know you don't have 12 words.
Every,
every single fan base has garbage
people in it. Sure. Every single one.
And people when they,
people act like that,
their team doesn't and they're
full of shit. You know,
especially when you're talking about
a sizable fan base, right? I mean,
maybe if you're like, I, you know,
I go to the University of Northern Idaho
or some shit where there's like 800
people enrolled. Okay, maybe
you're fucking fan base doesn't.
But once you're talking about like a
national fan base, of course it has every,
you know,
you told me about tailgating parties.
This is where people just get together
and drink and parking lots. Well,
of course you're going to act
like a holes. Some do, some
don't. I mean, I've been,
I've been in tailgates where people were
really decent and like welcoming and
nice. Um, sure. And look,
I mean some of my best friends
are Emmy graduates alarms.
Uh, I have friends, good friends that live
in Miami. It's not an anti Miami thing.
I'm just, first of all, I know you
do, it's a, it's a sports writer,
but you're supposed to talk shit about
your rivals was supposed to say that
they're garbage. Um, that was a
really good burp. I was pretty good.
Sound was good. It was crisp. Here's
the cheap thing that I did not,
I thought that was good burp.
The thing that was super lame
about sia talking shit about Miami.
I talked shit about them online after,
you know, on Twitter, just after the loss.
And they're like, I had people who
obviously don't know anything about me.
They were like, why don't you say
what you really mean? I was like,
what do I really mean?
And then they implied that
I'm talking shit about Miami,
calling them garbage people because
I'm racist. Like, oh, interesting.
One Guy and one guy implied that I
was racist against a Latino people.
Oh, sure. Sigora yeah.
I didn't even have to answer him because
everybody just like your mom's Peruvian.
Yeah. People attacked him
for me. Stupid. It's just,
I think that's one of the cheapest,
laziest,
most idiotic takes on criticism
is that you can spin it to that.
It's like a cop out to, to
talking shit, Talk Shit.
But also I'll also say it right. It's
like, I know you guys are garbage people.
And then to be like you're saying
that because we're like Latin, it's a,
not only is it cheap and lazy and idiotic,
which are three traits you find very
often with Miami fans. Sure. But,
uh, it really takes, it
takes the banter out of it.
It takes all the fun away from talk
some shit. You know what it is?
It's because the social justice warriors,
uh,
they're just no fun and they're out
policing all the fun in the world. Uh,
these are the new puritans.
They want to make sure that whenever
there's a whiff of a fun and levity and
busting balls, we're going to stop all
that good time because it's an prout.
Bring it out.
They're the same thing in November,
dammit.
Also something in November about
gator fans because it's a rivalry.
You hate the gator fans.
That's the fun of sports.
You talk some shit.
Those gators I know nothing about.
I grew up around surrounded
by gator and hurricane fence,
so I talk shit about them because of shit.
That's the fun of sport.
Who's dumber?
The gator fans or the Miami hurricanes.
They're people.
There's just
garbage people. I mean, you know who's
worse a Mussolini or Hitler, you know?
It's like they're bad guys.
Yeah. That's interesting. Yeah.
Should be fun for you when you do your
shows in Miami. I have nothing lined up.
All right, so let's go.
No, but seriously, um,
there was, it was ridiculous game.
It was so crazy and a finesse.
I will say, obviously wearing a
shirt smells really good, by the way.
You got to smell this shirt.
I've never smelled that bad on finesse.
And we spent quite some time with him in
a very hot country and he never smelled
bad. Um, and also, congrats.
Don't forget finesses special.
The spirit told me, right?
The spirit told me to say comes
out October 19th. I'll cover 19th.
I saw him on Instagram. He's aboriginal
thing I'm going to do for him anyway.
What's that?
I think I'm going to have a promo
cut to the seminal war chant for him,
for his best idea. Just to
like get the word out. Sure.
You know what I mean? Sure.
Just to help them out.
Help the right people like his stuff.
So I'll just a dumb the denim,
I'll plug it for him. I'll,
I'll send this kit for him and
then that way you know, it'll be,
it's like a promo and black. Yeah. Um,
so this lady, do you want to talk? Wait,
tell me what you know.
Here's the deal guys.
This one's really horrifying.
I like, first of all,
I like where our fans are going.
I like where this show is going.
Every now and then we pick up a meme,
a swell,
and right now we're policing
asshole behavior in public.
And I think this is a
public service we're doing.
So I went to Bark Williams and I was
getting ready for my mass asage and they
encourage you to use their facilities,
right? You get your steam room,
you got your, your fucking Jacuzzi
full of disgusting coach Broth.
I won't even go in the fucking Jacuzzi,
get your life.
I saw a woman with really hanging
tits hanger than mine or Nay.
Like I w in there just baking. I
was like, no, I'm not doing that.
But I go on to the steam room
cause I can sit on a towel.
So it separates my vagina from
other people's Shit. Right? Yeah.
I'm in the steam room.
I look fucking over.
There is a woman with shaving cream and
a razor and this nasty bitch is shaving,
fully shaving her legs in the
steam room at and that's that.
It's right. What is she doing
with each? Like I'm users swipe,
flicking it onto the floor.
I'll know this isn't your house.
I cannot believe it. I was, I almost
vomited right there. I literally went,
Oh hell no. Like I saw her, I sat
down, I looked over, I went, Hell No.
And I got up and I told one of
the staff, I was like, dude,
there's a lady fully shaving her legs.
I don't know what she's
going to shave next.
Can somebody like educate
her on etiquette? This is
completely inappropriate.
Discuss. So I got to, I waited, dude,
like I'm fucking waited outside and I
waited for the manager to, Oh my God,
you guys are so disgusting. And I
waited for the manager and I was like,
are you gonna go talk to her right
now? Like, I got all excited. You know,
like I just told I tattle tale.
And then she came out and I was like,
how crazy is that woman? How
crazy is that? When she's
like, well, we get all kinds.
And I'm like, did you tell her?
She's like, yes, she's been,
she's been told not to do such as, I'm
like, yeah, it's nasty. It's so nasty.
Why would you even need someone to tell
you not to do that in a public steam
room? Flick your hair. It's so disgusting.
Well now I'm totally turned off to using
any birth boys' facility or any spa
facility now cause I'm like,
oh imagine what this nasty persons
doing before you got there.
And then I had someone else tell me
their day. A acquaintance of mine go,
you know when I'm sick with
a cold or a sinus infection,
I go to Burke Williams and I use the
steam room and I feel better and I'll like
what?
Well this way too that can see my germs
leave my mouth and my face and I watched
them enter other people and I can
ruin everyone else's week basically.
I was like,
get the fuck.
I mean you think you try not to think
about that stuff when you use spas,
like how many people are clean and
it's not, I know it's disgusting.
I'm going to a clean,
sterile, no sanitary, no safe,
relaxing, wonderful place. Now, how many
dudes are peeing in the Jacuzzi to oh,
every two piece in that she cozy or
jacks off in there and yeah. Yeah.
And there's a sign in the bathroom at
the spa that's like you have to shower
before you gave,
you take a shit.
Basically you have to shower
before you use the spar.
The facilities know who's doing
that. Nobody. Nobody being gross.
Everyone's being growth. We also have
that thing in those spots by the way,
where they'll go. Some of them will
be like, it's European style here.
And you're like, what that means?
Um, trunks are optional. Yeah.
But basically most American
dudes are like, no,
we're trunks. But then you'll see guys
who are like, they'll give you the,
the San Francisco,
the San Francisco treat eyes and
they'll let you know that like,
I'm not really in the trunks.
Are you? And they I bank serious.
They give you a signal and the Jacuzzi
or some no, that'll give you a signal.
I'm just saying that there's
people that own it, you know,
it's like the guy that goes in the
steam room and, and does towel. I mean,
everyone would go in with a towel and
then there's the guy that opens the towel.
Like I just feel comfortable. Like I
just, I'm just comfortable like this.
And then there's the towel closed,
which is like, it's not necessary.
I wouldn't say it's necessarily
etiquette, but it's just, you know,
are you and wants you to see
what he's doing. Of course,
when he wants you to see now Europeans
don't give a rip obviously different
though here it's just more modest here.
Americans don't show their junk
unless they will not inviting you in.
Yeah. Or, or, I mean there's, there's
different guys that show their junk.
There's inviting you in.
There's truly, I don't care.
Like,
and you'll see it sometimes with
like a really disgusting body.
They'll give be like, yeah, I don't give
a shit. They're, you know, they're like,
everything's gross on the, which is the
most, I like the most, the one rating.
It's the most liberal.
It's actually the guy that has like zero
self conscious kind of shit going on
with them, which is great. Yeah. And then,
and then there's also the
proud buck where it's like, if,
if you're, you know,
six, five totally ripped.
You've got a 10 inch hawking. Yeah.
It's peacocking where it's like,
it's like they're not necessarily
inviting you there. Just being like,
I'm a specimen, so shit. Yeah. My
shits. Nice. Now what do you do?
I think I'm fair. I'm not like
hiding. Right. You know? Um,
I'm fairly modest wear. Like
I don't, I don't, I mean, I,
I'm kind of like the guy
who's like, I'm gross. Yeah.
I know no one wants to see it,
but I'm aging so I'm getting more into,
I don't care.
So I kind of hide my body and everything,
but I'm also like, I'm fucking gross.
Yeah. I'm a dad. I'm, you know,
I'm like,
I don't know.
See, I think you and I are
the same way. And the spa,
because I'm kind of, I'm like,
yeah, two babies. This is
racks. This is all fun. Yeah.
Like I'm never going to be able to be
single again and beyond the market.
Like nobody's gonna,
no one's gonna want this.
So I wear a towel like in the steam
room or the song, like I'll, I'll,
I'll be naked under the towel and
then all kind of sit in the towel.
Maybe unraveling a little kind
of thing. But I'll go, you know,
before this last encounter, I
would go in the Jacuzzi nude. Yeah.
But you're quickly, quickly, like I'm,
you protect the robot
just quickly go in there.
Yeah. I mean know I've done it.
I've done it before. I wasn't like,
I dunno,
it wasn't a big,
you made a brown and then they know
there's brown probably all over the,
remind me, remind me of that.
Especially dudes. They're fucking nasty.
Dee Brown dudes who's are nasty,
nasty. Brown's. Yeah, I know.
So there was that nastiness and then,
um,
there's like a waiting area where you
go to the spa and then you wait for your
misuse to come out. And
they're like, Christina,
like they're supposed to kind of whisper
your name. It's very quiet environment.
Yeah. And next to me, I hear
this older couple, just like,
what time is our appointment? Like
full volume. Horrible too. That ruins,
ruins it. Yeah. And that's, I can excuse
that. Cause the wife did go, Oh shit,
I think this is the quiet waiting area.
And then the husband, he goes, oh okay.
And then he gets on his phone.
Yeah. Tick, tick, tick, tick,
tick, tick, tick, tick whoop.
I'm like are you fucking joking?
And then the phone rings and it's
extra loud cause he's, hello, hello.
And he's, it's extra loud cause they're
old as fuck. Yeah. And um, yeah.
And then the phone call,
we're at the spa like are you serious?
We're in the quiet,
we're in the quiet room,
the quiet room. God,
I know what is wrong with people
gets your life. He's just like,
you just want an assassin on board who
just watches it and immediately fills
those people.
Can I tell you,
cause I've been to the Gaylord
hotel and Hungary and Budapest,
which is like the most
premier beautiful spa and you,
you know, you get naked. Yes. You go
on the thermal baths and this and that.
You would never fucking see
like a Hungarian like Oh God,
I like talking rudely. It's just,
they don't do it. You will be will be.
Somebody would fucking slit your throat.
That's what I'm telling you.
There's no way dude, like this is a
perfect time. Like what this full clip is.
I love it.
In the context of this here,
this video was recording in a Starbucks
employee asked the woman has stopped
having her call on speaker phone.
She loses it.
Craig crazy hoof man,
this, this, this gets heat.
We just showed you a frat show.
Here's where it started. Kind of.
Oh my God.
First of all, the audacity to
sit and I've been in a, um,
before I had, we had, there was
somewhere we didn't have internet when,
I mean it was like more than a,
maybe we weren't even living together.
It was like there's areas in your
life where you don't have Internet for
whatever reason. I think it
was in Hollywood. He had no,
I don't even think of it.
We were dating,
I didn't have a computer and I
went to a Kinko's or old, you know,
old FedEx Kinko's, I'm sorry, where
they have the Fedex and they have the,
they had like the internet
room and a lady like,
and then we were all sitting at
computers doing different things.
This lady who was on answering the
phone like she was at the office,
like her office having full
fucking conversations and
you see everybody turning
around with their bitch. Are you out of
your mind? Like this isn't your sweet,
it's just a public space. No, this is
her world. She's the, her Starbucks.
Oh Shit.
This may, she may not
be stable. I'm thinking,
I'm thinking anybody that
makes phone calls on speaker
phone in public, isn't it?
Look at this woman here,
not even looking at
gives the first time anyone's
told her to hang up the phone
or do you think this is something
that happens every day in her life
time.
She goes here, take your shit and leave.
Go get the forgotten you. Help you out.
You know?
I know Starbucks has this policy where
they call Starbucks your third place.
You got your home, you've
got your, what does it work?
And then Starbucks is your third place.
I think they should really discontinue
this logic of like come and hang out for
hours and surfing and do your fucking
office work here and waste to be like you.
You can come here to have a
drink and take your shit. Shit.
That's all we're here to do.
Take away all of this extra desk
space and put more toilets in.
They should change.
Let's just say we're not your third home,
but you can shit here. That should be
the well, cause that's a flaw of mania.
Starbucks is,
there's often just one toilet for
the entire is Starbucks lately.
It's inhumane.
It's wrong.
We're giving you [inaudible] juice and
we're giving it to all of you and we make
one too. Cups of bowel torture and
they're like, Nah, go shit somewhere else.
It's completely wrong. It's completely
wrong. Completely wrong. I know
I got it.
Yeah, lock it up. Good. Good idea
about things like this. No. Aftermath,
like not knowing what happened.
What happened next in the cops come,
she come back and throw a
fucking brick through the door.
Like what happened that
somebody that's worked?
I've worked a lot with the
public. I've had many, many jobs.
I've worked at Starbucks and the summer
of [inaudible] 97 we've gone over this.
The point is,
and I've waitressed many times,
there's like once a day there's
something like this. It happens.
Some person freaks out or if gets crazy,
the manager comes out, throws them out.
They might yell back at
you a few more times.
They might throw something
Majia and usually that's it.
And by the time the cops come,
they've they're long gone or maybe they
get a talking to from the cops. Yeah.
I mean there was a guy that jerked off
every day next to the retail store.
I worked out on Melrose every day.
We called the cops on him every day
and he'd show up in jerk off every day.
The cops would come every,
it was like this routine.
She's like a working professional
though. You know this lady. Scary, Huh?
Kind of job is, she's not like
a vagrant, you know. No, no, no.
A lot of times it's not vagrants.
It can be,
but just people who are just having
a day, she's having a day, who knows?
She's having a drag. Good
day could be like, you know,
we said it could be the dog,
could be as little guys. Yeah.
She's off her meds. Um, by the way,
it's October 9th when we
record this right now.
How's your a sober October cause there
were October. Um, well, you know,
silver October affects people differently
and there's different challenges for
different people. Yeah. Um,
I mean, let's go through it.
Well for like for instance,
and by the way,
I highly encourage anybody to take part
in this in whatever capacity they want
to take part in. It's just
a great exercise. Meaning
like some people go like,
I just want to give up drinking for the
month, but I don't want to do that. Uh,
or some people go like, I'm just
going to not smoke pot. Just do that.
There's no set of rules.
The rules are yours to make.
I just think it's good sometimes in life
to engage in an exercise of discipline.
This is your lent, so to speak. It's
sort of our law and it's just, it's good.
It's like, hey man, once a year,
it's something to mentally focus on and
there's just rewards mostly for yourself
to see what you're capable of,
you know? So for me, for instance,
I'd be lying if I said the sobriety part.
Was it challenged because I'm just
not a big drinking drug guy. Right.
I mean, I enjoy them, I
enjoy it, but I enjoy it.
Usually in mild doses.
Right. You know, like I'll,
I'll sometimes go two weeks without
anything without thinking or trying.
When I was pregnant,
I don't think you drank alcohol once
and that wasn't just because I wasn't
taking around you rank but see
dinners. Yeah, stuff like that. I mean,
on the road, honestly,
I'm usually, I'll pick,
if I'm doing a three nights out, I'll
have drinks, maybe one night get wrapped.
I just drank like normally what?
What's your, if it's at dinner,
if it's at dinner and like the night's
over, there's nothing, you know,
it's not pregames done.
Depends if sometimes you want,
I like wine with dinner. Red
Or white usually read. Um,
peanut, peanut, peanut.
Sometimes. Sometimes if it's
like a steak, I'll have a cab.
Sometimes I'll do a mall
Beck. Sometimes I'll do, yeah.
Pinot noir. But yeah, I
like wine with dinners. Um,
sometimes if I'm like, ah man, just
nice as weekends over I'll have bourbon.
Oh shit son. But I do, I'm saying it's
not, it's not that frequent, you know,
I just don't have the, I like, I like
beer with Sushi. That's outstanding. Yeah,
it's kind of rough. The older
you get. I just farting, I dunno.
And then as far as getting
high, I like weed, but I like,
I've discovered over life now
that I just like mild doses.
I like being able to function
and not have like paranoia.
And for me that means getting
paranoid well for me. Yeah.
I think that I have a low tolerance.
Like I've just, I know that I do.
So for me it's like,
it's not a fun endeavor if I go
over the line because then I'm like,
I just gotta get in my room
and cry alone so can, yeah.
So I like a mild dose, so I'm saying
the challenge for me isn't that part.
I work out separate from,
so Rocktober regularly.
Every week I do a couple of sessions with
the trainer. I do some stuff at home,
but so far we're on the ninth year.
I've worked out every day.
You're doing no days off, like on three
days off. You bragging about that.
Why aren't you bragging about
your new date? I'm doing so far.
On six of the nine days I
did two workouts a day. Yeah.
So that is the,
for me,
the fun or the challenge and the
part that's rewarding is to go,
can you actually do that?
Can you work out every day for a month?
Because that's a departure for me.
That's not something I would normally do,
you know? Right. For me, a busy,
like a heavy workout week
would be definitely probably
five days. So I'd be like,
Holy Shit, I worked out five days this
week. I'm doing every day right now.
It's a lot. Here's the
current standings. Got Ahead.
Now this changes and this
is just standings according
to our point system that
this app awards us.
Um, for people curious,
it's the Maya zone APP.
It's a attached to a heart monitor and
it basically gives you points based on
the percentage of your Max.
That's basically like a cardio reward.
As of right now,
as we're recording this,
I'm in first guide for you have
gene Ari's in second. Okay.
Burnt is in third and Joe's in fourth now.
Well I'll tell you,
this is like, he's gonna make that
shit up today. He could make up today.
He is annoyed by basically the fact that
I got this thing at the gym and that's
why I suggested it to these guys.
And when you go to the gym and you see
your points and you want to move up,
you work out to get your points.
Well,
the sort of shortcut,
it's not really a shortcut,
but the thing we figured out is that well,
you can just get your heart
rate up by doing cardio,
like elliptical bike ride.
And it wasn't the intent.
The intention originally was go workout,
get your points to rate a workout,
meaning cheat you guys. Well,
you know,
you still have to put in the time and
you still have to get your heart rate up,
but it just seems like a, a way
to get points. So he's like,
whatever. I'm, he's like,
you know, I could smash. Like
I said, we were like, yeah,
he was, um, you know,
he was like doing two hours of
cardio when we started this.
He was like, this is just
easy. Like I, it's not,
I'm just annoyed at how much time I'm
having to put in doing this time consumer.
So I think what, what, what
he's going to end up doing,
because we've talked about it,
is that he'll just go back to doing his
regular workout and get his points that
way. And then, because he basically
just wants to work out like that.
And we will do whatever we can
to be in points.
By the way,
we're all very close when I
just did that order there.
It's all within a couple of
hundred points of each other. Well,
Joe works out a lot.
He normally normal normal routine
is five days a week. Oh my goodness.
All of those five days, uh, I dunno.
Most of them are like brutal, intense.
I've seen it. Yeah. But he doesn't do no
days off. Now that's a special kind of,
yeah, no lunacy. No days off.
People really hurt themselves. Uh,
this is, this is no days off, no days off.
Oh, Jesus Christ. Last Day of
shooting skyscraper here in Vancouver.
It's been an incredible experience of
this city. It's the Rock, by the way.
Thank you so much for
opening your home to me.
Treating me like your one of your sons.
This is his, uh, traveling Jim. Oh Man.
This is his gym. He goes to every set.
The anchors that makes the experience
so special is every morning at 5:00 AM I
get up and I come here to my high on
paradise. This is my traveling carnival.
The traveling circus.
There's only 40,000 pounds of twisted
steel sex appeal and heartache.
A lot of harvest.
Mainly my own message of gratitude to
the small group who sets this gym up.
Every location I go to the next location
will be Hawaii when we shoot jungle
cruise. But this is a lot of
shit to move around and stuff.
Plus I'm a pain in the
ass because I'm like,
the energies has got to flow this way
and you can't keep your head that way.
Big Pain in the ass for guys.
Thank you so much. It's my anchor.
Plus traveling in a gym
like this eliminates all the
bullshit excuses not to get
the job done and get to work and so
I think you the studios. Thank you.
You guys are the best. My anchor.
Much love. Thank you guys.
You know what I liked about
a Miami graduate? Oh Wow.
You know what I like is that
he's got those rhymes down. Yeah.
That people have in the gen like teamwork
makes the dream work or whatever.
Like yeah, yeah. He's got his rhymes
down. Madeline's steel. Keeps it real.
That's right. You got a pump. If you
don't want to be a dump or wa he's got it.
He's got the right.
It's definitely got it.
So for those of you who aren't
watching the show on Youtube,
would you really should be?
Cause you can see the clips,
you can subscribe and you can watch. You
can also watch us on, uh, we stream it on,
what's that shit called?
Which we do at switch. Um,
we do a twitch now on Wednesdays.
It's usually like around five
twitch.tv/your mom's house podcast.
And then a few hours later it's
on youtube, but on the twitch,
on the twitcher. And when you switch
with us, you can watch it with us.
We jump in and jump in. Yes, I'm Dj Dad
Mouth One. I'm queen genes one. Yeah.
And we'll be laying in bed and I'm
in the Blue Band will notify us. Oh,
you're going up and
then we'll come say hi.
So also totally did not want not watching.
That was the rock.
And he travels with a gym. I, it's
a full gym. It's, it's like a gym.
You would get a membership to. It's not
like, oh, you one or two or three things,
a 40,000 pound gem. I mean, that's
bananas. That's his life, man.
He's the biggest movie star in the world
too. He certainly is. And He, you know,
he's also a former wrestler,
right? What is it? What is
he? Yeah, yeah, he was time.
So he's got to keep that shit up. He's
completely fucking yoked. It's crazy.
A mess. No days off, no
days off. No days off.
I have to tell the most disgusting thing
that's happened to us where you work
out or the elliptical
machine is in our home. Uh,
I come to find out there's been a little
friend who's living in our AC unit.
Yeah. There's a, there's a
separate a sea, it's like a wall.
It's a wall thing that has its own,
um,
condenser outside of the house.
And it's just for this room because the
room was an add on to the house. Yeah.
So we'd been smelling something
I think for like a week,
maybe kind of in denial, like, oh wow,
that's a smell. That's interesting.
And then uh,
yeah,
come to find that there's little
droppings around the AC unit.
Little shredding of stuff
like chewed up bits of air conditioning
falling out of the air conditioning unit.
And uh,
turns out we've got a little rat just
eating through the wire is living.
What we did was cocked up
every motherfucking hall.
Now it's fucking dead in there.
And also it smells much worse.
Well here's the thing,
here's the cool thing we have to
replace absolutely everything course.
It's at fortune tire unit, a whole new
condenser. It's really fucking hard.
That's all you do is the joy
of home ownership. So yeah.
Well first fucking so I'm, I wake
up at, you know, six in the morning,
find that this rat is in there.
First thing I do, cause you're,
you're not in town yet. I text our
rat guy because we have a rat guy.
Cause we live in an area where there's
lots of shit and he shows up an hour
later and he and I go around with
the cocking gun and just seal it up.
He puts poison and the AC unit did all,
there's so much poison in there.
If that thing's not dead by now, that's
like a bionic rat. I mean he just,
he loaded it. He broke it up into
pieces and if I can throw it,
I mean we killed that fucker.
I can't wait to see it's fucking carcass
to nasty rat is going to be really fell
by the time you see it.
Thank God it's not so hot.
I was kinda worried if it was old.
I think it's going to stick to this.
Dear Tom.
I tried to see if my wife was ride or
die chick. She is not without blinking.
She said she would turn it in
to protect our kids. So I girl,
what if our son committed the murder?
I saw her eyes start to twitch and her
brain fucking exploded cause she said she
would help cover it up.
What the fuck?
She said she would still
turn me in immediately,
but no way in hell she would turn it on.
This is your wife as terrible as mine.
Jared, I think you have your
answer already. I kind of agree.
I kind of,
why don't you think?
Why wouldn't he tries to
kill his mother is very rare.
How many serial killers killed her
mommy's? I know they need their moms,
but how it happens for sure.
Listen, to protect your child,
I would do anything. I
really would. You're an awful
person. I would protect him.
Awful.
Both of them.
Hey Todd and Krista,
last night I had a very strange
dream that I met Tom in the airport.
I was very excited to meet my favorite
comedian whenever said, hey Tom,
just wanting, you know, I'm a big fan.
Tom and sat down in a chair next to me
and asked me to sit down in the chair
beside me. He's put his arm around and
show up my shoulder and simply said,
go fuck yourself buddy. It sounds about
right. Quickly stood up, walked off.
My question is, are you as huge a
dickhead in real life? Thomas also,
have either of you had strange dreams
recently? Keep those jeans high and tight.
Bird is as fat as he is.
Racist. Austin. I like,
I love this new racist to me with his
comments are full of them and there's
basically every other person is
what did he do? What did he say?
Ah, it's so fun. So much
fun. First of all. No,
I'm a sweetheart. You can ask anybody
that walks up to me in public anywhere.
I always take time. I always talk.
Yeah. I always do pictures, whatever.
Anybody wants to sign anything.
Um,
but I do think your dream
is highly amusing and I love
that I was a shit deck to
you and your dream, but in real
life it wouldn't go like that. No,
you wouldn't do that. No. Hell No. I
could see you being a bigger deck. Yes.
The fuck out of here. I am so nice to
people when I meet them. Are you crazy?
Really? I am so nice to any,
if anyone goes, hey mommy,
and I'm out in public or yeah, I'm so
thankful anybody even listens to our,
our nonsense. Are you kidding me? No,
I'm never have any crazy dreams lately
without them. Yeah, you have. Well,
I'll tell you one weird.
I don't know if I mentioned this the,
the night that Anthony Bordain died,
I dropped about him.
You told me that already.
Yeah.
I don't know if I told him on the show
and this is before I heard about it.
I'm saying simultaneously as
he was in France, you know,
and I woke up, I just dreamt about him
and my friend texted me that he had died.
I was like, well that's Kinda,
that's a crazy one. Why?
What is this a setup for? No,
no, no. That person just said
they had a crazy dream. They ass.
I always have crazy dreams. What
I'm saying? You always do. Yeah.
What I dreamt about something I dreamt
about tailgating and I woke up thinking
how stupid it was. The
people do this thing. Yeah. I
don't like tailgating. Yeah.
I jumped about,
yeah.
I don't like crowds. All right. Um,
one here before we got to take it.
We have a guest. We have two guests.
Okay. We have to, yeah. Sorry, go ahead.
There's a few topics I want to get to
before we break because they're very
important.
Uh, hello shitless. I got a little
insight into the be whole munching.
My old lady always wants to eat this
grim and I always say no, Jesus,
I'm not a prude. And I do actually
quite enjoy it just like the gays,
but couldn't figure out
why I didn't want her to.
So with some long hard thought while
Browning I came to the conclusion that I
respected her too much as my
wife. Yeah. No, she's a dirty Ho.
I don't need her to spread
open the swamp for my pleasure.
She has no fucking idea what
she's getting into. Thanks.
I love you guys.
Isaac.
Yeah.
Cause he and loves his wife and would
never want to subject her to the horrors
of his Biehle piss on me. Beat me. Try it
out. Try it out. Yeah. What does it fit?
It's a foreign. Yeah. I don't,
I don't feel that way. I um, no,
you're just mean.
Not Mean I'm making a request.
You take advantage of my admiration
of you. I love you. I admire you.
Yeah. Like FIFO admires, get
in there. No, get in there.
Can I bring up one topic before we break
very quickly. Very important by the way,
that's important. Yeah. Okay.
So Tom and I are about to celebrate
our 10 year wedding anniversary.
Come November 8th that's isn't that crazy.
10 years already.
I knew Yaz Anus and,
but we've been together 14 cause
we dated for four. That's right.
And the other night you go,
hey,
I wonder how many farts
we've had together. How many,
how many fights have we shared as a
couple over the course of 14 years? Yeah.
And I thought what an interesting topic.
We should save it for the show.
Clearly our listeners would be very
curious to know, let's do the math.
How many times do you def,
here's your farting.
I'm going to do you're farting
average. I'm gonna calculate. Okay,
I'll pull up the calculator here. Okay.
You fart every morning. Every morning.
And I fought every morning too.
So let's rack up.
It's one in the morning and then you
definitely do a nighttime fort where you,
oh no. Yeah, there's a foreign in
bed. There's a Fart when you pee. Oh,
he's always talking about how many times
did we fart in front of each other in
14 years. Yeah. But in front of you? Yes.
That we participated in each other for,
I would say let's go
through your daily for,
I would say that like on average there's
probably a just woke up fart and far
that you do.
Right.
So then maybe like I would say
like two in the bedroom area,
maybe one in the kitchen. And this
is, are we still in the morning? Yeah,
we're still in the morning.
Coffee break. Yeah. Yeah.
You fart at breakfast and then I would
say there's a mid day fart for sure.
And then the lunch for the,
again,
I would say a two day is
probably on average. Okay.
Let me go through my morning.
Okay. So I started in the morning and
there's a morning for when I get up.
There might be a fart slips out
as I'm browning or peeing. Okay.
There's definitely, if we're
together, it's an after lunch fart.
Yeah. Especially on this Paleo Diet. Yeah.
And then I'm going to go for like an
in bed or watching our bravo. Sure.
You'd ever,
they don't hold back there.
I'm going to go for like half year daily
war ever time at four. You're at eight.
Let's do the math on that please.
Okay.
365 but we're not together through
65 but we're just going to act.
What's average?
What's,
what's a three 60 let's say doctor.
I would say the date.
Sorry, 350300300 days a year. But
let's say it together. Okay,
let's, let's do that. So,
okay, well that's easy for you.
So that's 1200 parts a year for you.
And then 14 years.
16,804 yeah. Wait a
minute. Wait, hunt. Well,
I'm 1200 a year of farts. And then
what are you, you're double that.
You're 2,400 yeah. Okay. So
this is a yearly you fart.
This is how many times I've
probably far right? Yeah.
33,600
Oh,
did you?
Okay. So you did 2,400 times
14 yeah. And that's how much?
33,600 and what's mine?
I'm half of that.
Yeah, right. Yeah. Well,
it's half of that 16,800
I farted in front of you.
Approximately 16 can we redo our vows
and then incorporate this knowledge into
our wedding vows? It's very
possible. It's a lot of farts.
A lot of farms.
Yes.
Can you believe there are couples who
don't Fart in front of me? General.
We're just talking to somebody about it.
Just talking to somebody who's in a
similar, I mean, two kids married. Yeah.
And he was like, no. And I go, well
yeah, I just hold it and yeah. And I,
and he's like, it's happened. But then
we asked like, what about your wife?
He's like, never, not once,
but think of all the fun you're missing
out on if you're not farting in front of
each other. Yeah. But maybe,
maybe because of that they're eating
each other's scrum or something. No,
they're not.
You don't know what about burps?
That's the next tally we got to
go to. Yeah. But he's real decent.
You can tell he's way more mattered.
Yeah. He's real deep. Yeah. He,
he saw Hamilton and he likes Hamilton.
I'll never fucking see that dumb
shit rapping, you know, like rap.
Like let's go get our guests are
our first yet got to get this going.
Okay, Mommy. Okay. Now
joining us is somebody who,
if you saw me last year
on the, uh, the no teeth,
no entry tour and a number of cities,
this young fine young man was with me.
Um, to a lot of those, you saw
me a tape to special in Denver.
This young man was with me,
young man and a,
if you saw me in New Orleans
or most recently in Eugene,
Boise and Sacramento this past weekend,
this was the opener who were very happy
to say we'll also be helping us a lot
more on the podcast with some
production stuff. And uh,
he's just an absolutely hilarious
guy. It's Josh pottery. Hey Josh.
Oh,
she was
such a good song.
This part's redundant by the way.
Oh yeah. She was.
Oh,
what course are getting muddied by the
whole damage once you do find Derek,
how you doing? Hey, that shit true.
It sounds like you've been
really analyzing the song.
Well, mudded is a gang. Bang.
I didn't know. I didn't know
that either. Yeah, it's an
other songs too. Really? Yes.
Little Troy talks about mountain
girls. Wow. Yeah. So you can't,
you can't Mutt a woman without
the whole damn crew. Right.
For those of you wondering why do
they have Josh around? There you go.
That's exactly why we bring Joshua. It's
redundant. Yeah, I heard you saying,
is it
t e d o Oh, interesting.
Another layer. Not mud and like,
no, I, that's what I thought too.
I was like, oh, it's anal sex.
But no,
when I was in Florida as a kid was just
a big tires driving through the mud.
Like you want to go mud and go Medan yeah.
That's also like hog in or what?
I'll pick up like a gross.
Uh, but this is, so you're
telling us it's mutton. Mutton.
We might ease go mutton with the cause.
I don't know what it was either. At
first. I want people to know how we met.
I think like they're owed a little
backstory. I met Josh in Buffalo,
Buffalo in Buffalo doing uh,
a club week,
a few years ago, and then we
did a bunch of gigs sense. Um,
you were on the radio there too?
I was.
And so you know a lot about these mics
if you don't have a lot of talking to him
and stuff. The tall, that's deep,
bro. We did an episode of that deeper.
That's right. Yup.
Right when I moved here,
that was like three weeks into living
here. Oh my God. How nervous were you?
Big Time. Nervous to let to live
somewhere new. But now you're here.
So how's it been? It's been like a,
has it been a year? It's been a year.
A little over a year. And how has
your experience been? It's been quick.
It went by way faster than I thought
it would go. Yeah. You took the leap,
take the leap. You took the leap. Yeah.
It's been a lot of back and forth.
Ups and downs, the whole
roller coaster. I'm not mutton.
We almost, we almost muddy this weekend,
Bro. We talking about right. That's why,
that's why I go on the road.
What's up with that sex life?
Are you getting your stick wet?
Not In la, no, not yet. Yeah.
Fenny any seventh for crew
ladies are out there. We'll stop.
I live on the first
floor I lived on first.
What is your Twitter handle
at j underscore potter?
Will you take or do you accept
nudes? Fuck yeah. Okay. Okay.
Checking. I think a regular, um,
nude recap. I think a nude and a sex
report on how your sex life. Well,
I don't want people to think if they send
me nudes that I'm going to expose them.
No, of course not. No. No. So you
send me nudes and you'll have full,
you know, discrepancy,
confidentiality, confidentiality.
That's the word I was looking for. That's
right. Yeah. And I don't send Dick Pics.
There you go. No, I don't know.
I do if I get requested them.
But you have to send five
first five nudes first. Jesus.
How is this going?
How does fee,
if you aren't worried about their
dicks ending up on the Internet,
like you're not afraid.
Like one day you become like a
huge comedian and they're like, oh,
here's Josh potters cock back in 2000
part of my brand could be part of your
brow. I'm the Dick Guy. So now I would,
cause I was never the single guy out
there on the road. Do you ever, I mean,
sometimes you know, we'll,
we'll do our shows. We part
ways. I'll be like, all right.
I mean,
do you ever go out there and you know,
try to hit the bar that people
might've been at? I wish, I mean, I go,
it's so weird when you're
alone in a place I don't have,
like, I don't put off good
vibes being alone in a bar.
So it's really difficult to, you
know, like who's coming up to me?
So when you're in a city all
alone, it gets weird. I don't know.
It's not feel lazy,
you know what I mean?
Just thinking about it probably is better.
Even though the statistically the
numbers are less, probably is better.
You better odds at Club after
club clubs are insurmountable.
Easier to music though, because your
intimate days. Yeah. Yeah. You know,
you're drinking in the lobby after
they're like, you can run right into them,
right. Theaters. You're like,
you kind of, it's really,
it's like the Gazelle are all
in the lobby in the bar area.
And if it's like a Friday, you could be
like, Hey, I'm got two more tomorrow.
Can we drink or something, you know? Oh,
right. You can hit them up multiple days.
So have you been,
are you a somebody that scores on road?
We go, I wish, I mean, I,
it's not for lack of effort. Uh,
I just haven't, there are times,
I mean, don't get me wrong, the only time
I've ever gotten laid was from comedy.
I didn't lose my virginity until I
started doing comedy. That's hilarious.
Isn't that wild? Like a killer? Like
how long ago was this by the way?
I was 22 when I lost my for, yeah.
Now he's like, after the Eugene,
you're 20, you're 22 and j like a
really good set that night. Um, no,
it was, I had to lay the
groundwork like I always do.
They probably had to see multiple sets,
really get a feeling for how
I was not on stage too. So,
but crushing in front of a
girl is like my favorite thing.
That's got to be great. It is dude.
It's the best. So is it the best?
What's the best? Is the best if you
kind of meet someone before and,
and you have no, no, that's the worst. No,
I'm saying, and then you blow him away.
Is that you at that it depends.
I mean if you meet someone before they
have preconceived notions about you and
then if you have a set where
you're talking about wild
shit, they're like, Ooh,
you know, they might get kind of
freaked out by the best scenario
is just killer set. Meet somebody. Yes.
And then they come up to you afterwards
and they're like, you were really funny.
And like, hi, Tom z did a girl,
Josh, I saw you up there and
you're really funny. We'll assess.
What are you doing later?
What's up? Uh, nothing. Uh, my,
I left my panties in my car. Oh really?
Let's go. See we're going to find
now she'd have like drunk girlfriends
and stuff too. Yeah. Oh definitely.
He's probably had, she's like,
have you had like the uh,
the deal got fucking
sidetracked by the Bachelorette?
Yeah. Sometimes. Well also
like Tiffany, no, he's crazy.
Obviously you went last time
when you and I do shows together,
it's a different vibe than like say if
I did a show with a single comic, right.
Whose only purpose is like
I got to get laid to yes.
And then I'm usually the guy that has
to play the defense for those friends.
You know,
he picks the target and then I'm the
one who like taking out the bogeys,
you know, that feels like it's a
skill though in and of itself, right?
I guess so. I mean, you
just have to distract them.
You really just have to lower your,
your own standards for yourself.
And he's not in terms of like the like
how they are just like in terms of like
not having any, any sort of
preconceived things going in, you know?
Yeah.
So you actually,
what you're saying is you will
actually spend time doing,
speaking to someone. You have no
interest speaking. Exactly. Yeah.
She's such a sweet guy.
Yeah.
You're so nice that when I'm out
there looking at it for a second wife,
number two, we're going to
have it. We're going to be,
I'm just saying you're going
to meet her on the road.
She's probably anybody's plan.
That's the best place.
Me and my friends think you're
totally, hi, me and my friends.
They always say it wrong. Yeah.
Growing up, how would you,
you would have a wife number two as
opposed to just having hoes in different
area codes. Smash city for a
run right away. You're no, Josh,
you're asking, uh Oh, I'm
dead. I'm gone. Yes. Oh yeah.
I have hoes in different
area codes. Wife, a mom. No,
I'm not going to wife up immediately.
It's smashed city for a while. Yeah.
And then the one who's like,
I'll eat your, but I put the
ring. Oh, stop it. Stop it.
Don't you dare bring those hose near
my children. Is that a sticking point?
Fuck you. You want it. And you
won't give a, it's constant.
Yeah. But it's also we just learned
from an email or a listener email,
it's a sign of immense disrespect
to ask your spouse. It basically,
this guy was like, my wife wants
to and I respect her too much. Wow.
This animal like,
I mean, that's true. Actually. That's
a good point. It's gotta be tough.
You're his wife,
but you get to a certain point where
you're so close that it's like,
who cares? Yeah. Nope. Right there
yet. You have to get to that point.
And that's what Josh, the
problem is, is that I,
I have intimate knowledge
of his dumps and his farts
and what he's capable of.
And I hear it every morning through
the wall. And it sounds horrendous,
but would you be deterred
if you hadn't had that?
Like wouldn't you still not do it
if I didn't, if I didn't hear what?
You didn't have any of that
knowledge? No, I would not do it.
It's just like nothing you would
ever, it's not, it's not for me,
but it will say Ryan Gosling's like eat
this booty from scrum and I floss with
his fucking pubes. Yeah. So you're not
against the act. It's just kidding.
I want to lane, but he looks
cleaner than, you know,
if he was like on all fours
and he was like, hurry up
and reach under and do the
yeah,
yeah.
Gosling. Gosh, I do like him
so much now. One of the things,
I mean I, I love about
Josh. He's a great comic.
Everything about he's great, he's great,
but we always have like, you're not here.
We always will like laugh at, uh,
you know, just fucked up clips,
things that, that we, you know,
we'll show each other things,
sending each other videos.
He's like your friend that's ground
zero for all the weird shit that man.
So I go look man.
So,
so to give people more information,
we've been working on a,
uh, transition to expand our show.
Um, there's, there's a transition.
I thought you're talking about your own.
I am. I am transitioning into a man,
but I do think like,
I grew this hair this weekend.
I'm looking more and more mail every week,
but congratulations.
Thank you very much. Um, but you
know, we're trying to expand the show.
We have a studio space that
were outfittings to, uh,
to start doing the show
from hopefully without dogs.
Dogs are part of the show, but, uh,
she's going crazy over there anyway.
We want Josh to,
uh,
to work with us in this new
space and pumped, so pumped.
And so basically, um, I need that to stop.
Can you please do something about that?
Hey, I know she's off of it. Uh,
she was going to go back just giving
him, how about we just pick it up? Do
you mean, how about you? How
about you picking? I'm asking you
so stupid.
In order to introduce you to the show,
the idea was that you would pull
some of your, pull some clips,
whatever you want to, you know, introduce
it to the audience. And I thought,
why not start with something?
I'm very well versed in pornography.
Okay.
Um,
here's all I know.
All I know is that I have four files.
Okay.
These are separated into four
files for us to genre genre's.
Okay.
Um, I'll let you direct.
I haven't seen anything.
I just knew that like we're
going to introduce Josh to
the audience that Josh is
going to introduce clips to us.
Is there anything I can, should I,
should I just play them at random?
I'm not at rent.
Maybe an order in the order that they're,
so the first one I see is died.
I did I do that. We can start there
because I mean, here's the thing. Yeah.
I mean maybe you don't
remember this because you're
married now and yeah. Got It.
You got to do all your business calls,
but most of the day I am in a hotel room
and this isn't stuff that
I TJ's to necessarily,
but when you just,
you have a lot of time after that
to kill and there's so much stuff.
These websites are like target.
It's one of the most interesting
things is like there's,
there's stuff that you like and
then there's the curious stuff. Yes.
It makes you go like is
that really a thing? Right,
exactly. And all these sites,
they put them there for you.
Like I said, they're like target.
You go in getting what you need and you
come out with a whole bunch of other
shit that you didn't even know existed.
It's pretty amazing. All right,
so I will start,
I'll play this.
I have a feeling that a lot of this
is going to be blurred out. Yeah.
Well this one is a pretty self
explanatory. Let's see what it says.
Let's see what we got here.
Uh, Josh Potter. Target. Yeah,
no,
that accent sounds familiar by the way.
And then she does see what's
this over here? That's a,
that looks like a Binky, right? I
mean, I'm not familiar with baby toys,
but I think that's what
she's using it for. Yeah.
So in case you didn't know
that she was going, uh,
he or she is showing you a better angle
to know that she is definitely gone
100%. This isn't just a
pomp and circumstances for
people not watching this,
showing you too. There is a pretty
attractive blonde Chang. Rub It in there.
She's wearing and she
just peed in the die,
die and she's showing us just making sure,
you know,
she also rubbed her at
her anus specifically.
She's getting the pee all around
there. Yeah. So important.
And in case you really didn't know,
so you really needed like definitive
proof that she really could. I don't know.
I don't know if I believe that she
writes. It can all be acting. Yeah.
And I don't like acting. I
want the real thing. Oh. Oh,
oh,
uh,
accent is very familiar to me. It sounds
like my old step mom sound like her.
Yeah. Yeah. It does. A vet. A vet
diaper. She would do that. Uh,
do you think she would do that? Yeah. No
I would. How much money you think that
I don't understand why every girl doesn't
have an Instagram account for their
feet. By the way. That's something
that's easy to get that money.
Do you think they get money? Just,
no, not just for posting them. Sure.
You get the build the followers, it's
like, oh, I'm going to start selling.
And you put like a bottle of tide next to
your feet or something. Product places.
Yeah. But whatever they, whatever's
selling ads out there. That's right. Like,
so then Ford's like, Hey,
we've got a new f one 50,
or will you put your feet on the
steering wheel? Yeah. She was like, yeah,
of course. Hey guys, you want to come in
a Ford? Yeah. I think you're right Josh.
I think every woman should
have of feed account, uh,
pissing in the diaper account. I
Dunno. I think it's a big leap.
You got to really jump to
peeing in the diaper. That's
more than feet. I mean, Hey,
if you can do it, do it.
But yeah, if he can do it,
I would do farming and paying in the
diaper easy. Yeah, no problem. Easy, easy.
There was some things in between those.
I would love Josh,
if you were a hot check and see this
stuff pull off with your knowledge now.
Yeah. Um, yeah. So that now
are, just out of curiosity,
are you into p I am not
into p this is this.
The thing that's weird about that is that
they're appropriating paraphilia. Oh,
oh, oh, right. It was like I went potty.
It's weird. Right. And the only thing
more evil than pedophilia is the n word.
Oh, okay. Okay. Good segue one up
here. I might be, because that next,
there's no video. That's okay. Okay.
There's probably a reason for that.
Let's see. Okay. Oh dear.
So I have a funny
question to ask you guys.
Is it cool if I say the n word?
It turns me on.
Just say the n word.
I'm young Nigga
and nigger day. Oh, okay.
What's she doing?
She's not showing her love.
I just see audio file. Yeah, there.
There's a lot of loving
going on in those lessons
right
now.
My favorite thing, by the
way, genre, it's a genre.
There are two facets of it.
Easy.
There are the women who enjoy saying it,
and then there are the men who enjoy
getting the women to say it. Oh,
fascinating. Yeah. So, so there's
basically the reluctant woman.
Yes. This woman. That's why she's like,
are you have any questions? Oh, right.
I have a funny one. Yeah, it was a silly
question. What's hilarious question.
Fuck you, nigger. Hello.
So what category is she?
She's,
she's the one who loves them and loves
saying it. That's what turns her on.
It's saying that word.
That's what we've done to the word.
We've made it so evil that it's now so
taboo that it's turning people onto stuff.
Genre. Like I wonder how many
people really are into that one.
I don't know. What do you think? What's
bigger demographic? Bigger audience.
The pissing in the die die or the
n word saying probably pissing.
Yeah.
Oh, you're the expert, Josh.
It's a brand of cause that's
something to be decent links.
Oh my gosh. Yeah. Accents
foreign. No, I think it's like that
accent is like Jersey isn't, yeah.
Yeah. Just whore. Whoa, Whoa, whoa.
Shit.
Oh Man.
I just love nigger juice.
Geez. Wow. Dark Shit.
Pretty physical by, uh, say the n word.
That cool.
Dumb like that. I didn't really read
a lot growing up. Oh yeah. Creation.
No worries. Where she says, uh,
is it called by say the n word
that that Dan Lauer the defense.
You can't see her in that moment.
She is skewered.
So
there is a, wow, just one fella there.
There's a couple of them. Oh really? Yeah.
She's a pretty bold to
ask such a question.
I think it was cleared
before they record it.
That's the fun part though is when you
don't know. Yeah. I have a funny question.
I have a silly, funny, quite
frivolous thing to know.
There are some that are like God that
are just like urine and word and then
they're like, oh shit. You know,
like they get mad but it's
ultimate reparations cause
then they punish the girl
for sure.
That's also the fun of the
video. Yes. Gotcha. Wow. Wow.
There's so much shit. Really
Nasty, nasty, nasty. Um,
she talks just like you're dumb girl.
Impression.
Do that as I have a five a class done
that I'm wired
and then you have to go up on every,
the out of fun to you are now I smile.
You smile ear to ear when I
come across those for sure.
Not because of them saying
the n word was just special.
Do you know what I'm seeing here? Oh
yes, this is a gentleman who is a real,
you know, these people that go around to
homes. And so what happened by the way,
is blue bear of a blue van prep these
so that he didn't have to blur them
afterwards cause this is all I have in
this is just a single shot. Well that's,
this one was pretty rough
according to hit him. So,
um, according to him, you know,
there are angels in world who go
home to home their caretakers.
They take care of people who are in need.
This gentleman takes it to
another level as you can see,
servicing a woman who is
a disable the disabled,
disabled,
extraordinarily disabled I would say.
And uh,
he is just,
I mean if you got to see this video,
you wouldn't know.
It would be like he was servicing, uh, uh,
a supermodel the way he is,
his vim and vigor, you know,
he really gets in there. Yes.
Which is just pure. I mean,
his heart must be so big. I wish we
had some audio from it. So is it, um,
you can imagine there's really not
much dialogue happened. And she's,
I mean she's, it's obviously like
a, an advanced chair that she,
it is some wild apparatus that is
difficult to understand how it exactly
operates being a layman
but incapable of movement,
incapable of her,
her lower body movement yet.
Do you think she, I don't know,
deserve Eugene at work work?
I think she's feeling something.
Does she make noises?
Yes.
That are conducive to
enjoying something like that?
Yes.
I'm surprised you didn't have any video.
I thought there would be a little bit,
but it is is great.
Gray. The blue band, it didn't put
anything in here. This is all shot clear.
That's all he cleared.
He told me it's a bit rough.
Wow.
And that guy sees everything.
So is this, by the way, in your churches,
did this all, was this a genre,
did you find it was, I mean people,
there are so many different
varieties of disabled porn really.
There are people with limbs missing
in my life, things like that.
Like the ones that the limbs missing,
they,
I think they really found their lane
because a lot of them use tools that they
then screw on to their stumps,
for lack of a better word for it.
And then they can have sex
better with these tools,
if you will. But yeah, there are all
sorts of, and I think those people,
if you have a fetish for disabled people,
you shouldn't be looked at as a monster.
You should be looked at as a hero because
who else is sex and those people up,
right? For sure. What do you do it?
I don't think I have the
bone or stamina to, uh,
maintain something like that.
Not like that superhero that we just saw.
That guy was real full
boar. He was, God bless him.
I Dunno. I really don't know. I
haven't been put into that scenario.
I wonder if women feel that way when
they sleep with me. They're like, oh,
there's a man. You're sleeping with a
blind boy. For people that don't know,
Josh has very poor vision. Yes. I'm
sure they can see, well, I dunno.
He can't hear that.
I'm blind. But yes. No,
I always wondered that if the women
feel like they're doing it a service,
when they sleep with me,
does it bother you to know what the
whatever they need to get through it.
You know? And I've had the
same thoughts. So charity work,
I'm like, I'll take the mercy. I don't
care. Yeah. Hell yeah. People listening,
Josh isn't as in totally blind.
We're not saying that.
So explain your cause he has
to be able to see these clips.
He's wonderful clips that
he's bringing it. Yeah, I can
see right there. Yeah. Yeah.
But also to be clear, he's well on
his way. I'm not flying a jet anytime.
Okay.
Um,
so that leaves us with one last clip was,
is this the save the best for
last kind of scenario? I think so.
I thought that one was going to
be last. Gosh. Well this is the,
this is all I have.
I have a couple of clips here at the end.
One is the n words pretty big. Which
one is the most wild too? So far?
The diaper stuff. I'm like, all right.
I think the n word stuff
is just bizarre to me.
Like I get some that toll sex thing,
like it's mental stimulation.
It's weird, right? It's taboo.
So maybe that's why there's some,
but I guess it's connected to hate.
Yeah.
I don't know what the connection is there.
Dad clearly didn't love and words.
I think the PA get cause it's all
the infantilism or whatever it is.
You get that one. That's the one
I least understand. You know why?
Because I changed diapers every day and
I maybe there's some connection to your
mom or your dad lovingly
taking care of you as you,
as you were if you were a baby.
So maybe they want to be cared for,
like they're small babies or
something. I don't know. Uh, yeah,
I mean I think the p one I
just kind of go like, Nah,
Piss the disabled one makes me think like,
well actually,
you know, everybody wants
some love and so, yeah, right.
Everyone needs something impressive
that the guy can do it like this.
Because I saw an interview with a porn
guy once and they asked him something,
they would ask him about this, but they're
like, what happens if like you, uh,
I don't know, don't like the girl
or something, something like that.
And he was like,
oh,
I always try to think about something
else to get me through the scenes.
I see. So there are different
place. Yeah. Yeah. So I mean, but,
but to be able to do that, I want to
know that Santa is not real in this case.
I like to hope that one's homemade and
that guy's just a hero that goes around
the community. The n word one to
think about that is that, you know,
it's very taboo,
which may be for everyone in that room
adds to the excitement of the situation.
Like makes the Adrenalin kind of pump.
I feel like if I was the white camera guy,
I'd be like,
he needs to chill the fuck out girl.
Be like,
because like I said, some of it is
because obviously this is a white woman,
some of it is the African
American gentlemen telling
her, I want you to say that.
Oh, right. Right. And then,
but my favorite is when
she is like out of nowhere.
I don't know where like, hey can I
asked some of them don't do that.
That's interesting.
The one that's down ass,
that's when we know they're
all like what the fuck?
But then they deliver a punishment.
Punishment. Yeah. That may make it,
yeah.
This last one I think is just fun.
It's just what happens here. This is the
last one here. It's everyone's scariest,
uh,
scenario.
US military forces are on their
way from what I understand. And
um,
we plant our seed in the
belly of the infidels the way,
although we'll grow with it
within, so this is like, this is,
this is nine 11 porn baby that is supposed
to be Osama bin Ladin is running out
for us. So some people don't,
they can't see right there.
It was like a summer look alike.
And another guy indicated in a cave
delivering one of those, you know,
anti-American message,
like look in the production is great on
it because it's all grainy and they did
it in a Web Cam and then Veronica
cane is live from Afghanistan.
I can't believe she got
that assignment so crazy.
So she's reporting back about it.
Um,
he'll fall into the hands of the
Northern Alliance and the special forces.
I don't think so. Veronica.
So Veronica says that,
uh, well she's just reporting on this live
store. She's just in Afghanistan. Yeah.
Covering the news,
covering the hunt for Osama female
newscasters have long hooker nails.
I'll tell you right now. I'm going
to ask you for the link to this one.
Let's see. Oh, they got, oh no.
First Daniel Pearl now her.
Oh,
touching our woman's boobs. Yeah. Uh,
I like how they speak.
I wonder if that's actual
three quarters of the,
what's going on,
a whole bunch of stuff.
I wonder if this is the
diligent lane birch. They are,
they've captured or they're torturing
her for answers. Most likely.
Do you think that's the real life?
That wasn't really blurred out. Well,
hovered three quarters of the screen
and left just a vagina and a dildo.
Do you think that was the proper
translations for the language? Think so.
I think they were like,
we're looking for authentic speaker.
Must speak Arabic and it's true.
It did sound just like,
wow, I wonder if they let Ronica
go after that. I don't know.
I mean what's worse?
Getting beheaded by them or
that's the, I'm all spitting
on her. That's the torture.
Who got off better though,
right? Man? That's gotta
be a fun scene to shoot
that one. Oh yeah. Really Fun.
I think I'd rather get John Mccain,
John Mccain.
Do you'd rather be like John Mccain like,
uh, I, I think, you know, I didn't check.
He got a w I'll have to dub him that.
Yeah, get captured by the VC. Oh,
they torture this shit.
Seriously.
Then be raped by a bunch
of terrorists like that.
I don't know which one I would prefer.
You want bamboo under
your fingernails or Dixon?
You don't want the Dixon? Me. Okay. How
about this scenario? Would you rather,
you're going to be with the VC and
they're gonna beat the fuck out of you.
Break your arm, fuck up your
shoulder, break your ribs,
knock you out a few times and keep you
for a year and then you're freed or three
guys spit on.
You stick Dick's and Dildos in your hon,
but then they let you go when
they're done. One instance. Yeah.
How often are you getting beaten?
You're getting beaten once every,
you get some form of beating every week.
Okay.
How would take the Dix from
the Arabs? Yeah, for sure.
100% over a year of beat down.
You get to leave after? Yeah,
but I feel like I'd be more
traumatized sex. Really?
Man,
I need to rough you up a little bit.
What would you take all the dicks one day?
A beat down every week for a
year where they shit on you.
I'm just getting beaten today.
It's a year,
but then I wouldn't be able to be intimate
with somebody after something like,
well you just go to therapy.
That's like how long is
their dildo session on?
It's like three and a half hours. I
could do it. They spit in your face,
you know, they call you an
infidel. I can't do it. And
then they go, this is like,
this is a message from my law,
and they look unloading.
You really ended up
three of them. Okay, here's the
bad part. The three of them,
they want to empty their balls
multiple times. Here's the thing,
what if they empty their balls and then
they liked liked America afterwards?
Your country is saying,
I can single handedly stop the conflict
in the middle of the sacrifice myself.
Yes. They're like, oh, blonde haired
woman, and then they're like, oh,
America's pretty dope actually. Yes. Okay.
I would sacrifice myself for America.
Yes. Oh, well I want greater good.
I would for the grant. Yes. I
didn't realize you had that in you.
I would. Would you? Are you taking
for fun anyways? Yeah, yeah, yeah.
For Saturday night for you to
answer sounded fun. Hell yeah.
I'll look at you two pigs spitting on me
and they're like American and for that
I'm like, yeah, what's up man? I'd
be like, I have a funny question now.
What would be,
do you think it be?
Yeah.
Worse that if all those guys um,
empty themselves in you rectally.
I have a good one too or in the throat.
Ooh Damn.
I would prefer a rectally proud I yeah,
because you can fart all
that shit out of you. Right?
You can basically shit ges out of you.
You can't get it out of your,
I have to check with a
doctor friend of mine weight.
But here's the thing that can give you,
like I say that.
Here's the thing though, they can
give you like, but herpes and stuff.
Do you know what I mean? Like he
knows better than mouth herpes. Yeah.
I would rather get the in my, but
then in my mouth. What about, yeah.
So I have a funny
question to ask you guys.
I would rather have, but herpes and
mouth herpes. Yeah. Yeah. Right.
Cause at least you can
kind of hide it from peeps.
You can really hide it
and I kind of hide it.
That's probably the best place to have
herpes is your, but I know is it, uh,
I mean, uh, as if you had to have
herpes anywhere, where would you,
where would you prefer other
than a doctor? A doctor friend,
uh, told me that, you know, he treats
all this stuff and he said that, um,
a lot of times guys are embarrassed or
just ignore to course all of this stuff
and we'll wait until it is like
a raging inflammation. Yes,
of course. What do they
ignore? A genital wart.
All the signs.
What are they like, oh, there's a
wart on my dick, but that's okay.
Going by the time they go, they,
by the time that he sees them,
it is completely covered. There's
a stench. It's like, it looks like,
it looks like, um, like,
like a feature film
Fx, like for, you know,
an alien on there, Dick Shot. And
then they're like, is this something?
And then they go to him like, this
feels like this should be looked at it.
This is why girls need to, where you need
you to not have sex with dirty dudes.
Yeah. I, uh, I did my fantasy
football draft a couple of
weeks ago. I know you like,
would you rather is my, uh,
high school friend posed one to me
that I thought was very interesting.
I think you'd particularly
enjoy this one. Ah, okay.
So I'll pose it to you.
If you had to sleep with Tom,
but it was your father's brain
next whatever the other one is.
Well then it would be Tom's
brain in your father's.
Ah, then that, oh
gosh. At least I could close my
eyes. Tom's brand, my dad's body,
unfortunately inside of the
shell. And I would, yes,
I would just block out in the
vessel and just thinking of Tom,
people would think you were crazy.
Some people don't choose that one,
isn't it weird? Fucked up, right.
Wait, what would you guys choose? Yeah,
I would try to choose the vehicle
over the brain. Oh, you would choose,
I would choose the brain over the vessel.
I think you have to choose the,
the brain. But that's
your mom. Exactly. Talk
to me, Dude. I'm about to come to know
because you have to start talking.
You'd have to keep reassuring me. Like,
don't worry that it's these voice me.
I'd be like, oh, shut up. I will
leave if I keep talking. No,
that's fucked up potter. Oh, sorry.
That's so hard. Are you today
are pouring discussion?
Both of you guys,
would you rather do the porno Middle
Eastern thing that we just saw?
You're just an actor. You're
the girl. Okay. And all those
guys fucking jet on you.
And it's just like what we have workday
or you do the n word scenario thing.
You're the girl,
but you're doing it in real life.
Like you're with two black dudes and
you're a blonde girl and it's real life.
And you're like, excuse me,
I have a funny question.
And you just kind of roll the dice and
layers to that one because I think a
pretty girl could get away with doing
that and I don't know. I really do.
They would be like, oh, you
want to say some shit? Huh?
Take care of it the same way.
I feel like it wouldn't be very
different than the porno Sydney.
Right. Am I wrong? It would, uh, a
switch it and let's turn the tables.
You're a white guy with a black
girl. Okay. Yeah, that was,
I have a question for you. Yeah. Do
you mind if I call you the n word?
Here's the thing though,
because this, this,
this applies to every time
the scenario was brought up.
What type of person are we dealing with?
Because if you're talking to talking about
this as a straight up animalistic sex
act,
like there's nothing that sexy thing I
think you can get away with a lot more
crazy. But if you're talking about like,
I went on a date or dinner and were like,
I got a silly little questions. I you,
yeah, I don't think that would fly.
Uh,
I know this might turn you off to
keep this one for third day. Yeah.
That's a scenario. It's this nice
girl. Like you take everything
you want to call her that and
you gotta ask, man, if it's
really your kink, I mean,
it's a bad one to volunteer.
I think you would,
what you would do is you'd probably,
you try to find a way there.
You'd have to with uh, without being,
you can't just be like out of the gate.
Say it. Yeah. You got to start like
playing music and get her take, you know,
maybe you watch something that you watch
some w Kamau bell show and be like,
what do you think about all this?
Where do you stand? Where do you stand?
And she's like, I mean, it's cool.
And you're like, cool. Who are you?
Like an activist? Cool. So
what you're telling me is
you, what would you rather do?
The Porno, Middle Eastern thing.
You're a girl or a real life.
Well, I need to ask this check if you
can say the end. It'd be terribly,
you've got one day,
it'd be terribly embarrassing for it to
go wrong. Obviously horrible, horrible.
But even that shame is not as bad as
being spit on and filled up by like in a
porno world, a bunch of terrorists.
Your job. Now this is just your,
and the other scenario of
the Middle Eastern scenario.
You're quite literally just like
the actress that day. So I get paid.
You get paid 50 old dollars,
so you get paid to do the
the porno version of that,
what you saw or a girl that's
your life or in real life,
you take the girl out and ask her.
Correct.
I think I would still take the real
girl and and risk being humiliated.
I'll take the payday. 50
bucks. 50 bucks. That's it.
Ah. Now you're making me
think about it. Realistically,
what do you think a girl gets for
that fit that 1500 bucks? I'd take it.
It's like 1500 bucks.
I'm, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I would take the real life scenario and
risk just because I don't want to be in
and be like on this
date with this nice guy.
I've got to ask you a silly question.
Side question.
I think a lot of guys would be,
would tolerate it.
I think it would fare better for you than
it would for us. Get Away with, we can,
we can talk some shit. He can say some
crazy shit. Yeah. You can be like, can I,
can I call Your Dad Fag?
And he'd be like, all right.
He might think he might be like,
it's kind of hot guys think everything.
And also what happens to
a guy who was a woman?
Like if you go on and ask a guy,
can I ask you a silly question?
Can I call you the n word?
No matter what,
unless he is really like his whole
life is doing the right thing.
He's going to be like,
this bitch is going to be the freakiest
of all time just for asking me that.
She's going to be such an animal that
probably most I think it would be like,
yeah,
sure.
And then they might even take a thrill
in like you were saying those things
where like they just didn't
punish you. Yeah. Yeah. Okay.
Now saying it as a guy to a woman,
that brings up an interesting
different scenario.
I might have to look up that kind
of see if that porn exists. Yeah.
That would be a totally
different dynamic though.
How unbelievably different scary dynamic.
Now what if,
uh,
what if you went out with
an African American woman
and then she asked you to do
that? I would. I would do it,
but I would be hesitant still.
It would take a lot. I'd have to maybe
have a few glasses of wine, you know,
it's so loosen me up a little bit.
Yeah. I don't know if I could be like,
and she's like louder.
Louder. You Bitch. I'm like,
I don't think I'd have that Alpha
in me to be able to do that.
Yeah.
Good stuff.
Thanks Josh. Really good
work track. That's why,
why we around really troubling.
You're ready? They are ready
for lunch. Yeah, let's go eat.
Let's go have some lunch and
we'll be back with another guest.
All right. So now the, the finally
the a, the moment of truth here.
This has been in the works for a while.
We've had to reschedule,
but now it's official.
Um,
I'm super excited to
bring in a great comic,
an La Native Felipe Esparza.
Yay.
Um, this is pretty crazy
because you pull from the, uh,
from those stem as a, as we learned.
Is that better? Yeah. Good. All right.
Um, it's pretty crazy, dude. Like,
one of the things I respect the
most about you is, I mean, you know,
every comic obviously respect,
but like your ride has to be,
it's like a,
it's really a fairytale. It's a
miracle. Do you ever stop and go like,
Holy Shit because like to go
from you from Boyle heights,
like for people that don't know,
tell it like tell him where
Boyle heights it when you pass,
when you leave downtown and you go
east and you see the first neighborhood
that's Boyle heights,
Boyle heights yet then once you
get to like a street code Indiana,
that's where easterly brigance.
Okay. So Boyle Heights.
So it's a rough neighborhood.
But I grew up in like in the intersection
where most of the housing projects
were in Boyle heights. Yeah,
because there's projects.
What kind of like a straight accords?
Pico Gardens,
Aliso village and Grando Vista
and all these ones where um,
I guess hazard. Yeah. Projects.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Hazard projects.
Um, I actually, if you see my
special, uh, mostly stories,
it opens with a sequence shot around
La and we went to the hazard projects,
non permitted to shoot this part.
Dude,
these guys like found us and
basically we're cool to us.
But they were at first they're like,
what the fuck are you doing here?
Because we were just with a camera crew
shooting all that footage, you know,
and then you can see some of them cause
I'm standing on that bridge that like
the overpass over there.
But I'm saying like it's great like when
you look back to where you came from,
like do you ever go like, Whoa, Holy
Shit. How far you've made it. You've been,
it's amazing. Yeah. I still
like damn that when I go visit,
go visit too much.
But like um, homeboy industries. Yeah.
Every once in a while when
I would go there a lot,
I will drop by sometimes just say hello
to father Greg and I will see like,
so when I grew up with, Yup. Who got luck
though? No, the kidney barely coming out.
Wow. And for people that don't
know, man, homeboy industries,
it was started as like a an
outreach program to give you know,
joggers and stuff. Jobs and tattoo
removal. It's pretty wild man.
And you come from that. I mean if, if
I would tell him Philippe at, you know,
13 that you'd have the life you have now,
you'd probably be like,
what the fuck out? And
I believe the man. Yeah.
I started going like acting like a fool.
I was older though. Like 19. Really? Yeah.
Because that way we liked school,
but when I got out of school with board,
you enjoyed school? Yeah.
And you, uh, did the,
were you in the comedy when you were
that age are now well, in high school,
a couple of friends of mine,
we were, we were walking home,
we saw these two guys like smoking a
lot of weed, smoking weed and yeah.
And there were just an intro.
Eddie Murphy delirious.
It's fast with a ghetto blaster,
like chill and smoke your weed.
And we still behind them too.
They kicked us out. Really?
Yeah. But that's what the first time I
saw, I heard someone do standup comedy.
But what about you trying it for the,
where did you,
where did you try at first at the,
um, natural budge comedy theater.
Our Fountain. It was like,
um, it was coffee house.
Did they comedy on Mondays
with Punk rock music?
So a punk rock band would perform
and where the next bite of set it up,
I stand up, comedian will go up and
do like an open Mike. Yeah, I bet.
I'll Jamie Kennedy there. Yeah.
And um, uh, lots of Boden.
Yeah. And were those guys
like encouraging? Were they
telling you? Well there were,
there were like, um, they've been doing it
for a while, but I was straight out new.
Yeah. I didn't know, but I was
dressed like Fozzy bear. Oh,
wear the coat lift of the
80. Who? The patch, let's say
what I saw in standup comedy. I just take
that. Everybody's just like Mark Pitta.
Yeah. All right. Right, right.
You got to get bids. Yeah. In
California. Yeah. California
guy out there.
That's hilarious.
So I was my first time at
all and it didn't have a tie.
So I found a bolo a board
red Johnny red core.
[inaudible] King of the hill.
And that was bald.
What? Yeah, cause I
just came wait to rehab.
So my hair was always balled
like a gangster. Yeah.
So it was completely bald and I believe
that I'm probably like uncle fester.
Oh my gosh.
Have you ever heard of, by
the way, I think called Cholo
Goth. Yeah. Prayers, right?
Yeah. I'm so stoked. You
know, he just married, she,
he didn't marry Kevin are going to have
a baby like you know the restaurant in
San Diego? Yes. I know. I'm a huge fan.
I somewhat, I was a goth girl growing up.
Oh Wow.
We really got the hardcore,
but see golf girls is a cousin of
the Chola look, it's very similar.
We like dark penciled
eyebrows, red lips, Pale skin.
So I hung out with a lot of chola
girls growing up. Immigrants,
Latino immigrants to golf
too. Yeah. And Morrissey,
they love Morrissey and oldies,
bullies, homie. Lot of Oldies,
man.
I saw this video of the
head. The Goth Wog? Yeah,
both a little basket do
that Mexico. So Rad. Yeah.
The first time I saw a goth girl didn't
know she came into all gothy a they get
worse. So she was dressed in
black? Yeah. It has to be funny.
Like his eighth grade.
Hey,
what happened man who died
and she turned around.
It was a perfect type when
she said you're a Bob.
Oh, fucking class lab there.
That would be your smart ass.
Yeah, but wet and wild cause
chola girls were wetting wild.
Same color red or the golf
girls were, yeah. So we,
we'd be at the mirror and you guys
with the heavy makeup. Same Shit.
We had the same, same thing,
but a different arrangement,
you know what I mean?
Did you have to,
did you go to high school down there then?
I went to High School at
Roosevelt High School.
Is that an in Boyle heights area or,
Yep.
Well Heights. Yeah. Dino de Rosa
about four 56 south Matthew Street.
La Lanes.
Yeah. Nice. I was in the swimming team.
I needed to make up my grades. Yeah. So
like my teacher, well the counselor say,
well you got to take tea. I like everybody
will pick another cool classes. I was,
it was crap, you know? Yeah. So I
had to go between swimming class,
swimming class or um, some
other bullshit. Right.
Like electronics because I was
when I was going to school.
Yeah. I don't know. Like if you were
going to school and I was going to school,
I was at the, I was barely where
they were getting rid of the classes.
They would always does Rio.
Okay. Okay. Yeah, like wood
shop. That was awesome.
You can make those fucking pencil
holder. Yeah. The metal shop. Yeah.
Dewberry reporting. You could
have finger yet. We took,
I took metal shop with in a 70.
[inaudible] like,
like I have kids now and I
would never imagine live do it.
Stupid clip. Oh, do we use a
jigsaw? Fucking what class or what?
Your fingers, all of them can be kind
on. I told him no one watched us.
We were like, we were talking
about Seattle. Yeah. Big
Chisels. Yeah. In the middle
class. Right. I show pot, you know,
like Braveheart, shame, making
swords. That class, I don't know why,
but it's trick galley
man will thousand oaks.
He drove a thousand logs everyday to
Boyle heights. It titled the Metal Shop.
He was bald.
Here's the retired naval worker.
Isn't that crazy?
But are we deal with big Ninja stars?
Yes.
I remember at chemistry class we, um,
no one anything to do with chemistry.
No,
I never even took it.
I was too stupid and when they came
we had a mandatory one and then the he
Kikina everybody was like, fuck
your class. And he was like,
I can make some shit explode.
We were like, all right,
everybody set up. We're like,
it makes your six close man.
And then they had the thing where like
if a chemical gets in your eye, oh yeah,
there's a unbiased wash
your clothes and it's like,
it's like a hundred pounds
of water per second.
Somebody pulled that shit.
Yeah. Not in front of them,
but like it was after hours.
Oh Shit. Huge flood. Yeah. Yeah. It's
fun. It was great. I took drafting,
drafting because that hard. That was
boring. Boring and hard. It's hard.
It's almost like it's, sorry. It's like
a more like you got a bunch of lines,
right? Yeah. Do you, but it's like
a millimeter or quarter range.
Like you had to learn the ruler for super
jealous of being able to draw me too.
I can't do that. She would have
drafted a generic business cards. No,
cause it though. I don't remember why.
Well we just made like cool drawing,
like geometric looking drawings and then
you got graded on whether or not you
did it correctly,
but it was drafted was where you make
a whole a whole pattern of a housing
square to here's the living room. Yeah.
I think that's where you can use it for.
But we went to seventh grade.
You know what?
The only class where that shit was looking
back, it was typing. I don't remember.
I remember typing. Yeah.
Here's the thing. Yeah. Yeah.
The PQ where you're like,
fuck, this is a comfortable,
my head hurts. Yeah. I took as
a cookie. Glad with this issue.
Tally. Okay. Japanese teaching.
You have a good memory? Yeah.
Oh, the other, the other
class of, well with a bad, I
remember, yeah, I was issued,
I got into a fight with some kid,
they Lalo and here because you know,
we're clouding each other and his
mom works at a fucking love's truck,
Salad Tacos all day at the park.
But he was in that class.
Are you fucking serious? So we were
like, what are the rocker dudes with it?
Hair at Levi jacket and yeah,
those little loafers.
Pendleton's whatever the law
wallaby's till you clown for that. No,
he'll call me called all dirty.
But the,
but then we were working
the, he said, well,
you trying to get these good an ed is
clay to take over the family business
motherfucker. He got mad. He
punched me. I got into a fight,
basically the, she totally to the
break in and she's loaded off.
She got pushed out the way. Oh, you're
a big dude then. You're a big guy.
I was little. I was like medium
size five, nine, five, 10. Oh, okay.
I would say it's one now.
Now when you, you said, um, like
that when you first did stand up,
you're like dressing this
way, you're bald, you're just
getting out of Rehab. Yeah.
Is it,
is,
is doing standup for the first time tied
to you getting out of Rehab was like,
you know what I mean?
Connected
in some way. Yeah. When I was in Rehab.
Um, how old were you? I was like 21,
22 years old. Okay. I was
in Rehab and um, I never,
I never really spoke in
public. Oh actually I did.
And kindergarten, but like,
you know,
you have an assembly with some kid or
read in Spanish wanted to do in English,
I would read in Spanish.
And um,
there's other rehabs, so they were like
a bunch of men, heroin addicts, everyone.
And this guy named Tim for the
separately and low value mission.
He was like a Catholic priest?
No, no. A brother, like naturally.
Then he did like the sad work
for the priest missionary.
So he will talk and come up with crazy
games. And then he asked everybody,
write down your dreams in life.
So I wrote down, you know,
I have a dream where I wake
up with no money, but I have
money whenever, you know,
or a nicotine class, he'll know. Not
those kind of dreams, your goals.
So we wrote, okay, I
want to be a comedian.
I want to go to Italy because I love
olive garden. Three, four, and five.
I don't know.
I love all the garden plan I know for to
get the bread and salad. That's awesome.
Until you really, you really, at
that time though, you're like,
I want to be a standard.
That dream.
Like I know you said you
first heard delirious,
but from then did you get into standup
a lot more after that? Yes. Um,
it was like during,
like we had a VCR and in the back of the
days of your borrow movie for somebody,
there's like six movie attached
to it. Yeah, yeah, yeah. So, um,
someone loaned me a standup comedy and
it had everybody's HBO special as a young
comedian was Rodney Dangerfield insurance,
the dice man and how he went down
specialists and that Robin Williams,
Paul Rodriguez, new job
with a little sweater. Yeah,
it was Paula. Mandy, you then because
he was a Latin guy. No, we know,
we know who we'd like to
hear more because we leave,
we related to him or his drugs
were silly, you know, funny for us.
We couldn't remember. I'm better like
kind of like Richard Pryor. Like I'm like,
I never heard of these jokes, but
my friends were, I remember, um,
poetry. You were performed at
Beverly at a Belvedere Park,
at this annual Latino,
first of all,
for Mexican Independence
Day during the 80s.
Like it was deep man. Like,
like if you went there,
you knew what gang was there and it was
mine or via mobile via projects because
of the fair was in the minor be a projects
bothered you ever connected to the
project so that we're Columbus
here grew up those projects really,
but their gang is deep Monrovia projects,
right? Like, I'm going to be a gang,
but it was like a clash of so many
gangs there. There was always a fight,
but I would never there I was too young
to go. But my friend will tell me, yeah,
Paul [inaudible] was there.
He throw it to tear the everybody
can do to control it,
but he goes up to tears.
It was true.
Or the audience would do it.
The fight come are backed
up by the Mexican frisbee.
That's hilarious man.
So that's,
I saw and then they shop boy
needs to lay in my neighborhood.
Were you tempted to get in gang shit at
all? Like being exposed to it? I got,
I wasn't like I got a job.
You did? Yeah, without,
cause I used to hang around with these
kids that were break dancers. Yeah.
They became gangs and we started selling
crack and that was where the heck is
wrong with him.
And what's that?
We were jumping a bunch of people
because they were doing bad and I started
jumping over to somebody say,
man, we do a jump your ses.
So then they got jumped in. Oh Shit.
So then you were in, yeah. Which gang?
Gang of the projects.
So they do run with them after that
for a little while to attach with a big
fight with my neighbor,
one of my neighbors when neighbors
called because whatever, I was like,
I'm out of here man.
Like I was on PCP. Wow.
No,
no,
that's the most popular
drug in my neighborhood.
Who would drive up and um,
the goal at this 15 [inaudible] a little
vial and dip like a new new port or a
coup cigarette and they had their
own pores and they'll be like, okay,
here's $15 all day long.
Get Wet.
Yeah. Yeah. So what does it feel like to,
let's say incredible whole cable?
Don't grade
like a woman,
like lift a car.
The parents,
you know,
if you're like already crazy and
you're mad when you're doing it,
you're going to go and do crazy stuff.
What if you're in a chill state of mind
and you do it? What does my friend Eli,
that guy was a guy that he fixed
everyone's card, the neighborhood,
he'll start smoking PCP,
PCP.
So I was fixing somebody Volkswagen
and he'll stay like, you know,
holding the wrench for like two
hours straight without moving.
But what happened to me was I just put it,
watch it terminated to oh
shows pumped up the APP man.
Shit, I was cheeky. One of those sports
bottles, you know those sports bottles,
NPM.
But I fill it up with long island ice tea.
So I was ready when it got
to the neighborhood. This
guy picked a fight with me.
He had just came out of prison. I was
like, I was like, because his old man,
what do you want to fight me? He was like
30, I was 22. Why you want to fight me?
Did you ask him?
You got into a fight with him?
Yeah.
And um,
because they call me Batman but he'll
call you be like fat man or Whack Matt or
Huh? Hello? Just, yeah, bad
names. What are they ignoring him?
But he started pushing me and
they're like, I'll take chuck away.
Then he pushed me, then I went for
the sucker punch I have missed.
Oh, how'd that end up? Oh bad cause out.
He caught a punch, be it, I'll paste,
my notes are bleeding and my mother
immediately punch me again. I
but then I started like, I don't
know, he was killing me. You know,
he'll fucking be up.
But oh he got,
he got rid of just like in a choke hold
one of those holes, you know? Yeah.
I guess a UFC hold they will
call him now to hold. Yeah. Yeah.
But you know people was talking about,
you know, this is what you good move.
This is what you do if you are
going to do is move, not matter.
This is what you do. You bite them off
earlier off, go left, go right away. Yeah.
For good about whatever they
touch you anywhere else. Yeah.
You buy through her off they let go man.
Yeah.
I've been happy with can you
let go ahead right there.
She started crying like a little girl.
Whoa.
Cause it's always pinging
him up and you don't matter.
That's one of the, I want to see that
quarter of Carter fight. And though,
you know what happened afterwards and how
it, what led to it, that's a real fight.
Even ever been pudge. You don't, you
don't know what I'm talking about. Yeah.
So the adrenaline was going
and PCP was in my head.
Is it a full bottle?
It took me about it.
I thought a whipping him look up like
an idle board with a belt. Yeah. Wow.
It's when meg who call
on his face. Yeah. Nice.
But I blacked out after that
other than no anything have a,
but they told me that,
um,
his brother's jumped in and I felt both
of them and they beat me up because I
knew I had more helicopter
blood on my tee shirt. Whoa.
He paid his fucking ear off. Yeah.
The tip. Did you taste the blood?
It was, I don't remember better.
What's the, is the feeling in PC?
Is it body high? Your
whole body? Like you feel
very slow. Very slow.
Hmm. But, uh, but uh,
I guess the anger triggers it. Yeah.
Well, they say sometimes, you know,
talk to cops about, you know, uh,
fights they've been in and how like a
guy who's really amped up on PCP can,
they can have like 10 guys
trying to take them down. Yeah.
We'll fucking keep it.
Correct me if I'm wrong,
but isn't this one LAPD started using
Taser guns choke holds because of like
PCP, PCPs. I want to say no, I'm
serious. I think you might be right.
They couldn't like restrain people and
they had to start shooting them with the
Taser guns.
They might be,
you might be right and if you even got
shot with a Taser on a PCP, you'd be like,
wow, like you was like
your favorite drug. Then
the, the last time I did it was
then. Yeah. Oh Wow. Okay. Well, yeah,
you put some guys you're off. It's
pretty wild. Yeah. But it's funny,
like people would just pop
out a PCP joy anywhere.
Like birthday parties. What? Yeah, man,
I was at a birthday party, like,
come holy the goats, you know,
like behavior gold with rice and beans,
tortillas and birthday cake.
They, somebody got a Batman
that it goes to poke a PCP,
joy over there that's
said, all right. So I,
my foot two bites and a
little of their red smoke,
the smoke with it and dirty with
it later through in the car.
Ah.
They're like,
Holy Shit. What about,
did you ever do math
crystal meth? Not like,
um, everybody, you know,
when there was some old dead yeah,
I didn't know how to do that.
Like I thought it was for losers.
Yeah. Well math was popular in the
90s if I recall everyone highs.
It was cold ice, right? Yeah. Or, yeah.
And you're a stepsister. Yes. Yes,
that's right. Had a little
problem with it. Yeah.
It was pretty popular in the 90s and
it was always in the clubs when I was a
goth girl. Ever. All the goths are doing,
you can get into that. No, I didn't.
I was afraid of it. I was afraid of
it from the stories are what I just,
I from Nancy Reagan, the dare
program yet, but I did other stuff.
I did LSD. I did, you know, pot, other
shit. I just thought it was nasty.
I just knew it was synthetic, you know?
Yeah. I didn't know how it was made.
That's what scared me about math.
It's like just some dude in a basement
or whatever about mushrooms. Yeah.
Well that's, yeah. You know,
the material for the first time, like
three years ago, really as an adult,
I've never done it before. I wish I
would've done it earlier. Yeah, it's hard.
[inaudible] earlier, they don't know the
drugs because you enjoyed it that much.
Yeah.
I was watching the other watching clothing
culture the first time for the first
time I'd ever seen him
before. And you would do it on
mushrooms. Yeah. I loved it.
It was awesome,
man.
It went numb when he's building that
mountain out of play with my kneecap.
No.
Um,
we've had this ongoing debate going on
here about ride or die for God's sake.
This one, the weigh in on it. Yeah. Well,
here's my scenario. Even married before.
Let's start there and married now
know you, man. Okay. So, yeah. Okay.
There you go through and
you've got children, so
you're, you've got, yeah. Yeah.
You're fully an adult. Okay. Perfectly.
He's a grown ass man. Go ahead.
So am I asking him if he's going
to tell no, but just whatever.
All right, let's say ask him if
he thinks I'm right or wrong,
but what his life would, yeah, it's a good
idea. How about that? Well, I'll say this.
Let's say,
um,
tomorrow you're hanging out at the house.
Your wife has some things to take care of.
She comes back home and she goes,
what's up babe? And you're like,
ah, I gotta tell you something
while you were out today,
um,
Amazon [inaudible] dropped
off a package and you know,
the, the box was all torn open
and uh, it was all broken,
so I ended up killing the
driver. Um, so anyway,
he's in the trunk of my car. I
just need to go like, handle this.
Now do you think your wife calls the
authorities on you or does she help you
hide the body?
Super.
Call the authorities really damn oh two.
And what it would put out to kill it
too. You'd have to kill her too. Well,
why is that? Philippe? Walk us
through the logic. Go ahead. Yeah.
Tell us why you think she would tell it.
Turn you in. Because of the murder, man.
You know what have you killed her?
Ooh, that's what I've
been saying. That's magic.
Because if he's going to turn on
the Amazon delivery guy for nothing,
he's going to turn on me. He didn't turn
on the Amazon delivery guy for nothing.
The package was torn open and got it.
Everything was broken.
So he's going to say it, but now you think
he's going to get me next and my kids,
I got to protect the children.
Yeah. Yeah, man. Look at that. You
don't know what's going to happen next.
Oh,
all our time
was two of them. Yeah.
Yeah. And what did you learn
man, when you were up a carpet?
He's got a bird. The floor.
Yeah.
Have a buddy. The carpet isn't a burden
of the Lord man. Fibers behind. Yeah.
Little hairs.
Especially the project has curly hair.
They were still unfortunately curly hair.
That is the quote quote of his show is
never kill a person with curly hair.
Uh,
this says that Diaz
his ride or die. Let's see what
this is in a file, Joey. Yeah,
this is
rather die.
I love you motherfuckers. All
right. Have a phenomenal day.
Don't let nobody fuck with
you and it's your world,
these motherfuckers and visiting.
All right. If you don't want to eat,
you don't eat it. Don't do it. Just
because, well, my baggy. Fuck. Fuck them.
Fuck them and get rid of them.
You got to get good people in
your fucking solid fucking savage.
Don't give a fuck.
If you stab that mother fucker at
three in the morning and you call them,
they say,
fuck it.
I'm going down to the belly out
and I'm going to stab him again.
Those were the fucking people you want.
If you don't have those people,
they just fucking acquaintances. You know
what I'm saying? I love you. Stay black.
Boy, that didn't come up
McCullough. Bingo. Bingo.
Bingo.
I love you motherfuckers.
How much do you love Joey
Diaz is the best, but I'm
gladly, but he sides with me.
You're the first guest we've had. So I
don't know that flip his sides with you.
He does, but Phillipa has said that he
thinks his wife would side with you.
Well, well, but, but he said
that he has, she has to turn.
Oh yeah.
But he's always,
he's going to fucking kill her next
hit when she doesn't know that. Yeah.
He said I got to kill her too.
I think she wouldn't have turned me in
or getting me at a two hour to get away.
At least that's the nice thing. Now here's
the thing that's a ride or die move.
Totally right. I would give you a two hour
head start. And that's what writer guy,
sorry, tire up. Wait a
minute. Don't get my yes.
I wouldn't say what'll cause
that'd be kidnapping right there.
But you're already a murderer in.
So now let's flip the scenario.
You get home, you're like, hey, I
got some pastries. And she's like,
I got to tell you something
really bad while you were out. Uh,
I kill the air conditioning guy. Do you,
uh, do you call the authorities on her?
It's your wife who's going to
take care of the kids all around.
I'm asking how was that for the
air conditioning guy is she goes,
I stuffed his body in the closet,
so are you going to help
me get rid of this or what?
Nah, man, no, let me make
an accomplice. Right. Wow.
So He's thinking he really is
realistic. Turnberry. Really? I like it.
He's actually putting thought into
it. Yeah. Being very grounded.
Is that what we call it? Calling
the Popo or why? I was like, oh no,
we'll call it lawyer first and sort
of what to high. What's we'll do.
Oh, get to the heads. Oh,
smart. Then call the cops.
Then I called the cop cop that I know on
Facebook and then I'm asking what would
you do?
We just give them a hypothetical.
Imagine if your wife just have
a funny question for Fred here.
What would you do? He'd be like, Philippe,
what are you asking me this for? I Dunno.
I'm just curious. No, I liked
the way he thinks. Lawyer up.
Number one call a lawyer. That's actually
the smartest one we've heard. Yeah,
I might do that first and
then give you a two hour.
I think that's a problem at all. You're
right at the lawyer where he wants to do.
I say, you know, we know where to go out
there and go eat what you want to eat.
Right. To solve it in
an hour. Right. Yeah.
He probably wouldn't tell
you to go get that last meal.
I never thought of that part. Yeah.
The food ain't too good in prison.
A real like a tried through and through
lawyer with experience would be like get
laid. Yeah. Get laid, get paid, get.
Yeah, get something to eat and uh,
we'll go,
we'll go after that.
It's kind of stuff I was going
like that if I was gone like that,
even though I'm Vegan now.
Yeah.
I will fucking just eat like three
fucking big males. Yeah. Yeah.
Are you Vegan? Really? Yeah. No Shit. How
long have you been Vegan? So like 2012.
That's how long ago was this a
were you prompted by your wife? No,
I was,
I'm doing the Atkins Diet and I was
just eating cheese and meat, but it,
those shit over the Gig or no water.
He'll just soda cheese and meat
that I was constipated because they,
the shit sure. Went to the
mosque class and they're like,
fuck a rip. I will play a lot of shit
lab blood really owe to the people.
I felt like I was raped by a goes.
So you're saying that the Adkins Diet,
you couldn't take a shit so then yeah.
You were like, I should probably go
to Bama. I will do the vegetables now,
so I want to be in a,
um,
I started eating just of bishop
shoppers with no more meat. Yeah.
Yeah, man. Yeah. I guess which door to
our Vegan. Wow. Well, good for you now.
You feel better now? I feel
better. Yeah, you got it.
Like nothing but Greens in you.
It's great. How are those dumps now?
Stick you. Yeah, but easier. Easier. Yeah.
That's good. Um, so somebody
messaged us the, they said,
I've been reflecting about your
studies of gender transitions.
I was especially intrigued a couple
episodes ago when Ari was a guest.
Christina asked who would make the
prettier woman between Ari and Tom.
And then again on the episode
with, uh, Christine Hazel Decker,
when Christina wondered if town would
make a beautiful woman after transitioning
attached as a graphic I created that
help you better visualize what the
transitions of some of your favorite
comedy pals might look like. Okay.
Definitely some handsome ladies
in this bunch. Uh, enjoy.
Thanks for making me laugh. Genes, Chloe.
All right. Here's what Chloe made up here.
Oh my God.
Oh, whoa. There you aren't Tommy.
I looked like such a slut
with no facial hair though.
I know your eyebrows are not on
fleek. I mean, Ari does. He does.
Joey, Joey's aerify, Frito Flintstone.
Burt looks just like a fat southern
lady, right? He looks like the, um,
the ghost whisperer or wait, no,
the second theme. Yeah. Yeah.
I was kind of something. Yeah.
Let's also kind of like the,
what's the fat racist holiday
holiday kind of that race a chef.
Yeah. I could see him being like, I
gotta tell y'all something really medium.
Yeah. Medium. That's right.
Um, and then Joe. Oh,
Joe kind of looks like a slot. Who's
been through some shit, right? Yeah.
She definitely only knows to blow you
on a first date. That's what she said.
That's her compromised. Yeah. She's
like, I had a good time. I blew him. You.
I also think it has to do with the
highlights. They made her look sluttier.
Yeah. Your makeup. All your
makeup's terrible. Ari is
like made to be a woman. Yeah.
He looks way better than you guys.
Joey actually looks like some Cuban women.
I've seen it and has heard that lady
that a booklet party show called how many
soda you drink?
That was soda to drag already
a man. You look terrible. I look
like I've been through some shit,
I think Bible where people, yeah,
let's rank them on the ugliest Joey.
I'm sorry Joey. I love you, but not a good
woman. He's number one. I'm the ugliest.
Then probably now I'm going to
go to birds. Terrible. Yeah.
I think because of the fillings. You
know what this looks like to skin tones.
You know what this woman looks
like to me? The, the Burt woman,
like a really sad woman who
puts out a positive vibe. Yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
More like GCF for the manager
everywhere she goes. Definitely. Yeah.
She like she asked for the manager,
which is also like,
I just feel like she's
like, oh, y'all, uh, how,
how are things with you
all doing right now?
And then you find out who filed for
bankruptcy. The inside is chaos. It's all,
it's all fucked up. Yeah. Yeah.
Um, and I are pretty tight.
Pretty. You're number one for the ugliest,
ugliest, first place. Joe Eds. Okay.
Second place. Bert Kreischer.
Yeah. Burnt Chrysler. Sorry, Tommy.
I'm going to give you third place for
the ugliest welcome for us Joe Rogan.
And then the prettiest is Ari. So
Ari was right. She's the prettiest,
prettiest transitioned woman. Yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah. You feel like it?
Yeah, go ahead. Would you rank them for
leaping ahead? Exactly like that? Yeah.
Tommy, what do you think?
Yeah, I mean I will go like,
I will go wah, like prettiest
one, two, three, four, five.
Who is the other one is here. One
is Ari to his top three. Yeah.
Three store Forzberg five five,
five. Yeah. That's the order. Yeah,
yeah, yeah. Joey's looks amazing.
Yeah. Some Shit, Huh? Yeah, she was,
she was rode hard, you know, in
her, in her younger days, messy.
You are kind of like a girl,
but I also looked at it a little bit like
a burn victim because they had to like
pencil off my beard. Makeup's not
great for any of you guys. Yeah.
But they are able to find a
hairless photos of the other guy.
You look like no bullshit though. You
know what I mean? You're kind of a means.
I've been hurt. I've been hurt. Yeah.
This woman's been hurt a lot
and you know what? I'm not,
I'm not going to get hurt again. You're in
law school too, you know, fucking shows.
Oh yeah. Yeah. I learned
to read as an adult. Yeah.
I'm teaching myself the law. Yeah,
yeah, yeah. You're no nonsense.
You're a single mom, so, oh, this is total
single. You're single mom. Yeah. Yeah.
Ari is just that college slut.
I'm like, don't you feel like he,
this is a women's studies he gets,
he gets muddied by the whole seven
cruise up. Yeah. The whole crew's there,
but on the download. Oh
yeah. But he's a fan. Yes.
He's in feminine style or women's
Studies. Yeah. Everything's okay.
I'm not going to his dorm or holes,
bounce of that ass all over our floor.
Nick new tico modest in the seventh
floor. Seven train. All of them.
You so don't bring on
lasers. We're gonna run a seven man
train up all in you. All up in you. Yeah.
Jeez. You ever heard of that damn
seven floor crew? He sees some shit.
I seen some shit. Some Shit, man. Yeah.
I went to a swingers
bar and um, Phoenix. Oh,
I didn't know they had that many,
that many.
I feel like Arizona is a lot of swinging
a lot of shit out there if he makes man.
Yeah. Florida clovers shit. Yeah.
Uh, the PR, one of the,
a friend of mine told me
that he was hanging out at
a club one I comedy club and
place shut down.
So it was just like a green room hang
out and an orgy busted off. No. Wow.
Yeah,
the happened or that
happened when the orgy,
but people get a lap dance after the
comedy show at some place. Some show.
I didn't think Scottsdale Low Scottsdale
here in la somewhere. Oh here.
My promoter.
Hmm.
And it just kind of went from there a
little while to get our lab lap dances.
We haven't even got paid.
I left a show one time and Ontario and
the next day that the guys were like,
why'd you leave last night man?
She got really crazy to hear that.
And I suppose I'm saying that Shit.
No, it was, the staff was like, yeah,
I got,
we had to forcibly ask people to leave
because they were doing some not so legal
things in our green room. I was like, Oh
shit. Couple of our friends were there.
Wow. Okay. People we know like
not going to say anymore on that.
I think I should probably not. It was
a long time ago. I'll tell you off
Florida is fucking weird. I've
been Hartford, you know. Hey,
there's a hot tub back at our house
like by the owner and his wife.
If you want to join us in the hot tub.
A lot of swingers in Florida.
A lot of swingers.
Yeah.
Hot Tub is always the move. That's how
you get people to fuck thankful for,
for people that want to fuck more
as I got hot tub. Yeah. Yeah.
It's that by like, oh, doing a
show. And that's the city by sure.
There'll be a lady with three.
Terry's
their prosthetic, I guess. Yeah,
but she just put a fake TV. Why?
But they'll tell you what she's going to,
she might go to the show.
She didn't go to the show.
Whatever. I got to see her
like in what movie was that? Total
recall exactly that. That, yeah,
but the third teddy
damn. Unreal. Unreal man.
Be Great for breastfeeding.
I know. Right? Um,
and then you also, by the way,
I didn't want to forget this.
You're one of the few guys I would
feel like, I feel like there was like,
I'm probably underscoring it,
but you did last comic. Yeah.
And I dunno,
I feel like there's probably five or
six people that that show was actually
designed for.
In other words,
good comic gets great exposure
and then capitalize on it.
And you're one of those like five or 6:00
PM because a lot of people in the like,
you know, in the execution of the
show you realize you're like, oh,
they weren't ready for this show. Yeah,
they were just on the show. But it,
but it had 30 minutes. Yeah. But
you're one of the people was able to
make, was that a fun thing to
do? Yeah, I thought it was fine.
Like a lot of the top five comedians,
they already been the real headline
before there had been a Letterman,
they'd been on stuff that didn't
have it. They even had what, six,
seven and who like who was
in like your final few?
And my final one was Roy was jr,
he's a very funny Mike Kaplan.
Yeah.
I know my homies from Mike Destefano.
He, he died rest in peace and um,
Tommy John Again. Yeah. Good
comics in your final five.
But the people that were
like at the top 20, top 40,
they were also did well like
Christian alone. So she got up,
she got her show and Tiffany Haddish
and no rail and they were all on your
episode. Yeah, that's a good lineup.
There's some, there's like over the years,
I mean it always stood out to me
like people who were ready for it.
I think Ralph, he was obviously
somebody who was perfect for him.
Uh, Bowden was really ready for it. Um,
uh, you, I didn't realize him. Rod, man,
he's ready. He's been
doing it forever. Yeah.
I can't name him after that.
The last winter wasn't even
announced on television.
Seriously. That's true. Who else do
we know of us? We sit in my email
was a bunch of claps emojis.
It's pretty good.
I didn't know like TV so thorough.
You know, they check everything,
the background check I was going
to get into the show because, um,
they found out that I had a bench warrant.
I didn't go to,
I think I failed to appear
at court three times. Ooh.
So that they're looking for me still.
But it wasn't me. I told the cop,
I told him private investigator for
NBC and the lawyer looks at Man,
I got arrested one time and the only
person who knows about that as Canada when
they go together, then you got to
rest in Canada? No, but it all,
it only shows I got to the
outright. Right, right.
That's the only one that it comes up.
So it was my brother and my brother
committed those crimes, not me.
So I have to go find a photo of my brother
and then they compared the first one,
I lucked up with a person who didn't
get locked up. They let me go,
no shit. But there was a comedian
on a show that I know personally,
they cut him out of the photo because
they were going to kick him out of the
show anyways because of a criminal or
something. So when they took the photo,
I saw that they grabbed him and put him
on the left side and they cut him on a
other shit. That's fucked up, huh?
So what I want $250,000 back by
son's mom filed for child support.
Go light material.
She be,
she be killed. The lab baby mama
standing, he followed next day,
the next day she got
like $140,000 tax on that
plus the after like 10% of all that I
felt like in that movie with Tina Turner,
I just walked by name.
So we may have a $250,000 winning prize.
Yeah,
two kids.
And um,
that's what I don't understand how like
you could all just $25,000 in child
support, but um, every
month you don't pay,
they add another 300 and it keeps adding
up and if he's adding what you keep up
the two 50 you, you kept like, like a
hundred or something. You got ID at 90.
It's all good. All right man. Well yeah,
but here's the thing though, for you,
that wasn't like the,
that's what I'm saying.
It wasn't like the one off
you want and then you're done.
You were able to like parlay it and we
went on a tour on a 85 city tour and I
got paid like extra more than the
contestants who did it win. Yeah.
And I got paid more than them,
so I got 85 serious.
It was like an extra chunk of money.
That's awesome.
But I mean you've also since then,
just never stopped working.
I never stopped working. I'm very
busy. Yeah, it's great. It's awesome.
But then my special ed data on showtime,
it did well showtime.
But then when the people saw it,
but then they sold it to a,
to Netflix and that did really well.
And then you also did an HBO one. Yeah.
Yeah.
And um,
I got to think the Netflix or the
new president, he is the guy from,
I think Montreal comedy festival.
So that guy,
when he joined [inaudible] he put my
special backup on Netflix. That's awesome.
I have, I explored and
athletics. So congratulations.
I'm working on doing another
one, man. I'm going to do a,
hopefully I'll do a half
hour special and Spanish.
Do you performance the Hell No.
So when I learned how to speak
English at four years old,
so he spoke fluent Spanish for four
years and now and now I'm not fluent in
Spanish so I don't know all the words.
Can I ask you this?
If you were going to do a half
hour special, would you do,
um, you, would you work your act out
in English and then just translate it?
Yeah. That's how you do it. Yeah.
I've thought about trying to do a set
in Spanish or thinking of doing the set
from my old special cause easier, but then
now I just want to do it all new. Yeah.
But he's going to be tough
man because I don't know what,
I didn't even know what they like
or what's going to be offensive.
I think it was, was his, who's Trey Hill?
And I just Google the other.
I just wrote down my bits and have Google
translate it. Oh and you had the uh,
yeah. Did you do it? Yeah,
I did it. How'd it go?
Did it went okay?
I got to look at word like Hermaphrodite
I'm intimidated by it. I'll be honest.
Cause I just feel like it's not the, uh,
the language of it,
which I definitely
would have to, you know,
practice. But I always feel,
I feel like is the way that I do stand up.
So in tune with American culture that,
that,
you know, like then I'll
say it and there'll be like,
this is fucking weird bands.
It's not about that.
Yeah. I mean standup is all
about cultural contexts,
old knowing the boundaries
and knowing it really well.
That's why it's such a miracle.
Understand that sensibility. Right?
Cs a non native English speaker do
stand up in America and you're like,
how the fuck did you, there's
this Japanese girl, um, I
ego, I think her name is.
Anyway, she does Sam. She's
hilarious. Yeah. Is that, do
you know, I'm telling you,
I go right. Hey, cool. Yeah, she's great.
And I'm like, how the fuck are you doing?
She's a, came over as an
adult, I'm assuming. So, yeah.
Then how do you figure out what, what I
gotta do it? Are you going to do the I,
they asked me, hey, Susan asked me, uh,
uh, what's his name? Francisco Ramos.
Oh yeah. They've told me that they
both do like to all Spanish shows.
I got to try it.
I did Spanish.
I'll put together like a seven minute
set once for us by the television show.
They went well nice. But it was
all my joyful in the first measure.
So last set of punch line.
Yeah. I don't know what you call
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] per day,
Huh?
Oh Man. It saves the team
but won't have sex with you.
I met the woman that I have stayed
asleep with bootcamp and he sex,
he'll write it tomorrow morning
cause you're getting no food.
Yeah.
I think your style will actually
is better for translating. Yes.
Because you are very clear cut,
set up joke.
Right where like I ramble and like my
joke might be here in a three minute long
thing. You might be able to pull off
joke, joke, joke, joke, joke. Yeah.
But I want to do the special,
like if I get a chance to do this better,
I want to do it just for like
American and Spanish speakers. Yeah.
I don't want to go to
Mexico. Dude. Over there.
You know I'm to Telemundo style
balance, right. I'm getting old Spanish.
So if you get a ghetto ghetto Spanish
people who barely speaks English like you
know like the people that
we see all the time. Yeah.
Those guys like the people who sell
the bootlegs, those guys. Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah. Cause there's such a
different, the Latin culture,
what's a show we watch that's, it's not
called Sabado Domingo, but I love it.
Come on man. When we were in Florida
and Miami, we were in the hotel room.
We were sick. Nah, still been
Domingo. Which one? I like Domingo.
It's on for like six hours.
And that guy,
yes.
Right. See that sense of humor.
Like I kind of, I could kind of,
it doesn't translate. I forget his name.
What's his name? He's been a forever.
Yeah,
he's German.
He's German but raised in Chile and got
caught by the way guys worth like $4
million cause yes, I know that show
and he's been doing it forever. But he,
I'll go on,
I'll turn that on and literally feel
like I don't understand Spanish.
Like he can be too. Half of his, why?
Why is that? Because of his accent.
His references is also like, like what
he's like, where is it? Show films,
where is their building? Miami I think,
but he's to lay in. But it's like,
it's so ingrained in like,
you know,
in the now of what's funny and also,
you can joke with expressions
and terms that it's,
it's that are kind of on the out outlying,
you know,
border of, of the lexicon. Right?
So if you start saying like,
even something like, you know what
I'm saying, you know that that's,
that's not how you would learn English,
but that's how people speak English.
So he's doing the equivalent in Spanish
and like making reference to, uh,
you know, maybe a, a soccer star,
his wife that everybody knows
in Mexico and like a politician.
It's specific. Yeah. Is
references you don't get.
And it's also phrases that I'm like
completely out of touch with. Right. So,
because even the slang varies just
like here and in, and in Britain,
the English slang varies.
And you have to remember in Spanish,
the slang varies from country to country.
From Mexico,
Guatemala to Columbia to
Peru and Argentina. All the
slang is different things.
Yeah. Town to town, man.
So I dunno, I, I watched,
I've watched that guy for an hour before
and picked up on like two jokes of a
hundred. I bet. And you know,
it's cool that that show is it,
they'll do like comedy sketches and
then they'll do like a paternity test.
Yeah. Yeah. It'll be
like super serious. Yeah.
Then the next segment, then the
glow light, the new glow, like
Maria [inaudible], most dual mama,
like I'll quiet Medea Mama.
And they both are at the moment,
35 years.
They'll tell you that she left,
her daughter hears Oprah adoption
to be wonderful. Her mom was,
and then there's little patchy
look bar comes up poor as hell.
Like the girls like rich, now that
we well, okay. That was really good.
Okay, man. She, she's, she has
to give her her daughter, man.
She don't want to be like this.
Yeah, yeah. It, it was dusk.
Dads would I choose here on television?
Funny Man.
Yeah. Pour the tears and he's, he's a kid.
Gloves where product placement. Yeah, he's
a smart thing is for sale in Nashville.
I didn't, did you do, have
you done that show that I did?
Um, yeah, that's worth it.
My step. Me, I think it was Joe Diaz,
you guys did that show together.
Maybe you look at the video, he's talking
real fast. If Georgia has forwarding,
is piracy. Wow. Deep two top
poppy. Yeah, that's a Ito, Papi.
That's like him. Say it over
and over. He's fast too. Yeah.
Well you that you play dude, here's
the other thing. They put you aside,
pull you aside and they go, Hey,
uh, this is a Latino television.
Like yeah, no, no shit. Yeah.
He's like, so you have to
do everything bigger, right?
You have to do everything bigger.
Which also by the way plays against
my instinct for comedy in English,
which is to play everything smaller.
Right.
And you let the small stand out.
Right?
So it's like saying something
and you're not showing it, right?
Like that's kind of your instinct.
So you know,
they had did this thing where we played
this game and then they pour beer down
my pants. Yes. And so
when they like they go,
the first time I reacted, the guys
like react bigger. He's like, Yo,
it's for Latinos, like you have to.
So, so then I did it like jokey.
So they poured down
like Hawaii and they were
like, that's perfect.
Like keep doing it.
Or they did a, we did a game where they
bring out like a beautiful girl in a, uh,
in a zip up in a, like a gold. One
piece is zip up and they're like,
uh, we're going to put
items hidden on her body,
inside her zip up and you put your hands
on her and you guessed what the item is
and they tell you ahead of time, we're
going to swap her out and put a guy there.
That's the joke is that you think
you're touching a girl. But again,
they were like, but
overplay it, overplay it.
So like you put your hand in and I'm like,
yeah,
oh cool.
Deanna, like that stuff.
And they were like, so,
and then of course when you find
out they don't want you to go,
it's a guy you have to go like
hi.
So it was,
it was,
that's what I learned in Spanish class
in high school. Okay. Lasting mark.
It was like no one says that shit crazy.
That's,
it's hard to do all those stuff because
you go in and tell you something,
I don't do none of this shit.
Yeah.
And I did one love his show,
but a of another show
that could test and I was,
it was these two, like these two girls,
they were actresses who were real pretty.
There would a kiss sitting next to me
and our heads were sticking out of this
little cage. And then I guess dumb stuff
on top of us if somebody gets it wrong.
So there's the w the pretty
one of was both pretty,
but they thought she was alive.
Expected.
She's like makeup Dodd looking all cute.
They dump dirt on her
fucking dirt,
bunch of fertilizer at grass and then
they put a bucket of crickets down.
Damn right there. The other
growth that what the hell she is.
They dumped like hot sauce
is beginning songs. Chips.
They must have been so pissed
about the directly. Okay.
It can't be that bad for me.
Mad the tub like all like teen
dirt that we're it. Goggles,
fuck this.
I don't want to eat none of this shit.
I closed my mouth and I looked down
and there were like 30 scorpions.
Why hasn't even started
looking for this bad fuck.
I'll do it for 300 bucks though.
So a
real fucking scorpions and I don't even
know like a Scorpion will have their own
agenda, you know? Yeah.
Cause they said fuck for Lipez eyes
this night that this book is Cobra was
talking Shit to me. Left
bucket bucket toward students.
They go free these fucking like they would
add each other bad like it was like a
prison.
Inmates getting let out of the hole
is the only chance to fight hold.
So those go, it went out and
they left me alone. Oh my God.
You thought is screaming like you
did. I went big Bro. Ah, they love it.
It has been one of my mouth.
You Scorpions crazy,
I guess are the ones you eat. I guess. I
don't know what fucking show is is again,
that's the Neato TV
10. That's brutal though. Yeah. I
didn't realize I got that wrong.
They're the blindfold you and they slap
you with a Burrito. Is it again? What,
what type it is? I saw that. Yeah,
but that seems funnier.
Like lighthearted. Yeah.
Not Putting Scorpions on poor
guys. Hey, crickets crisis. We get,
he saw that.
Sue them for something like that.
It's pretty crazy money to sign
something before you did that shit.
No, that was coming, ma'am. Liberte
asking me back and go listen man,
because I don't want to get slapped by
loaf parish. I, it would've put out,
I don't want to put my face in the
quarry of foot of lobsters. No Way, man.
And they're like, [inaudible]
it up. You're like, I got
it. Yeah. I don't want a boy.
I don't want to be thrown
at me. Unreal. Mosquitoes,
mosquitoes,
caterpillars.
Um, somebody asked here, they
said, uh, can Tom point out
where this guy went wrong?
What should he have done differently?
How would Tom go about this?
Let me show you what this is. Gene, maybe
you have an opinion on this too. Okay.
We'll leave a shocking case of a
customer behaving badly at a fast food
restaurant. New West police are searching
for a Sass back to got way out of hand,
throwing a drink,
allegedly assaulting a
customer and damaging retail
equipment apparently. Okay.
Over a frozen beverage. Is that
you Tommy? It doesn't shock me.
I have very strict guidelines for my
drinks. You know, at coffee shops.
This guy, I think when the men
in pink is about to lose it,
when words are exchanged,
fingers are pointed and that
glass that just got cleaned,
it's about to get really dirty.
This September six fast food restaurant
assault or the peers should be sparked
by a Tim Horton's ice camp. I guess the
order was wrong. It was incorrect. Oh,
you think
you're the only coffee blended
drink over the counter.
This irate individual
begins kicking and yelling,
stopping briefly to check his phone
before moving off screen to let off even
more steam.
The reportedly punched and kicked somebody
who tried to intervene after he was
insulting and degrading the staff.
This guy, he's cute. He's got it together.
It looks like he's got PCP that works out
PCP. Yeah man. Good steroids, eyes,
five foot six man wasn't computer
printer and gift cards. Go Fly.
Police want to id him
to us.
It's concerning that somebody could
become this I rate and this upset over
workout
over incorrect order.
I think it makes a lot of
Tim Horton's employees have had
to deal with a lot lately in May.
A woman desiccated and tossed
the mess inside of Langley.
Tim Horton's now the newest Smith's g
man eventually took off leaving one heck
of a mess.
You know what they say about the customer?
A little lazy and he just told her totally
Sinjun Alexandra, CTV news Vancouver.
What's that?
Lazy that they lady right there
doing there now did you be filling
it up with food or something?
The Lazy like pretty sure
that guy probably tired of
her lazy ass. There you go.
You probably goes into it all the
time. They keep fucking that up. Yeah.
They have a personal gripe with him and
he went to go too far, but I can see it.
They don't make lazy employees.
Thank you. I tend to agree with you.
I mean it's like I've asked for extra
ice every time you're going to come from
Burger King and you, you, you got your
soda like four ice. I hate that shit.
Like [inaudible] where he could feel it
swishing in there. He could just tell how
lazy, what to just grab. Yeah, exactly.
He just tapped it. I do that thing
where they go like, uh, they're,
they're kind of dicks about it.
Sometimes when you go,
I always ask for extra ice in my car,
my ice coffee.
So they'll either put five cubes and
where I go, hey man, is this extra eyes?
And they're like, yeah. I'm like, okay. Or
the person goes, oh, you want extra eyes?
Okay.
And they pack it so full of ice
that you can't put a straw in rude.
So I have to actually remove some.
And they're like,
I thought you want an extra ice.
I'm like,
you know exactly what I'm fucking asking
for. I'm asking for two scoops. Size.
It's a little extra ice anyways.
I could totally see.
Got a Tim Horton's.
I think they should.
They should find that guy to give him
whatever the highest award as you give to
a citizen. Like hey, thanks for straighten
out these people at Tim Horton's.
So tell you know like if
you're like at a restaurant,
he took it out on the waiter was not
really his fault because he was going to
grab the food from the loser
as cook. Right, right, right.
So you really can't take
it on her weight or,
but right here the latest was
standing right next to the,
the middle or drink or soft,
you know this,
she is responsible for that drink through,
no, I always side with the
employees. I've had never do that to
an employee. I worked there. I had a new
tire man. I take care of that of people.
So I used to work at a restaurant
and this guy came. Yeah.
Adding that the hot dog was under cook
overcoat on the cook and then I saw the
hot dog cook, actually kicking the
hot dog playing soccer with they,
with the other cook. What I did,
he picked it up and they, they,
they put it back on the grill and then,
um,
it got the little bird and they give it
back to the guy and that guy gave him a
$5 tip for having an extra burden.
But then we'll kick it now other
than a floor earlier. Yeah.
Never actually witnessed that
kind of, you know, revenge.
I don't know. I've never done that.
I've never done it. I, you know,
I've shortchanged people,
but I never done that though right
there I've kept extra change.
Like if I get extra change and like,
fuck yeah, dude, that's your problem.
That's a wipey not an MP,
but those are mistaken.
I will tell him to give this guy less
money and they're looking at his 20 and
that's it. Well, he took it.
Um, what are you looking at? I'm trying
to find the, uh, I have to pee really bad.
Excuse me. I'm trying to find the, Oh,
we got to get them out of here soon.
I know he's got to go. You
got it? Cool. Yeah. Got a big
thing today. Oh, you do? Okay.
Yeah. Okay. Hold on. Oh, yeah. Here. Yeah.
What happened? I want to
follow up on a, hey, Julia.
Okay. All right. One second.
All right. All right. Um,
I'm just going to show her one last
thing and we'll get you outta here.
I know you've got to go. Um, but, uh,
oh, remind for this weekend.
Did you already say, Oh
yeah. I'm going to be at the,
um,
the Call Hall Center and Houston,
Texas this Saturday and Friday.
I'll be at the majestic theater in
Dallas and Dallas, Texas next week.
A be at the Tampa Improv.
Come check that out. Also,
I'm [inaudible] funny bone,
but I don't know what month it is,
but you can check out [inaudible]
dot com my first time there,
and I'm coming to Seattle at the more,
the more theater and I'm coming to Denver
for New Year's Eve. The paramount. Yeah.
We'll get there a day early. Hang out. You
don't smoke pot, Huh? Yeah, I smoked pot.
I looked at a lot.
I thought I thought you were the one
that's more when you said you there's mold
PCP.
I thought you were the one that smoked
PCP was Tracy Morgan at that Tracy Morgan
PCP story now birth birth story. Oh,
okay. Yeah cause I was, I did. Um,
cause I remember I, I
didn't know that. I'm good.
I know that I'm Jay Moore will
tell him that story. Yeah,
yeah, yeah. That was the,
that was their, that was their thing. But
then it was you that it was, you know,
that was him. I was like Nah, I can't
push it down. Some words, I'm so grow,
do a PCP or we're actually having a,
a cover they issue with Tracy
Morgan for longer than an hour.
Dude. But your story, you said
about Bruce Bruce on point. Yeah.
I work with Bruce Bruce and Mike Epps.
Yeah. And he was cool. Huh? Super quick.
Like if I'm Bruce Bruce makes
fun of somebody who make
fun of them off these two,
how real smooth. We weighted those shoots
where, man, what's happened, this lady,
we're wearing flat shoes
and he looked at me,
goes Phillipa because I lady shoes her
shoes that her path or for the heights.
He's so funny. He's a total natural
soldiers. We know it's funny. Two hour,
like I watch a lot of Netflix but I don't
have to watch the whole thing cause I
don't want to get influenced
by the common got watching.
So why don't in 10 minutes and
if there's 12 hot, it's hot.
Like you're the heart and yours too.
I'm not just say cause I'm here,
but they watch them.
Oh awesome.
I actually chaired your and I said it
goes from another immigrant with a special
yeah. And a pullover.
You Lavelle Crawford.
Oh my God.
He was first 12 minutes are fucking
hilarious. Is it on Netflix? Yeah,
I showed it to my son,
my step son, he's 14.
He died and he went to go
show it to a stepbrother.
He does this bit about uh,
how they show like people are
prices, right? And who, who livers.
So they show you shit they
never see before their lives.
So he does. He goes long.
It does like every question.
They're both funny man. He's so funny.
We were just watching him last night.
Better Call Saul. He's great on that.
Yeah. He's so skinny now. He lost,
yeah, the picture. He
was like after a joke.
Yeah, he's great. He's so funny.
Um, okay, so just set it up.
Just so you have reference for this.
This is the guy.
So the story is that a guy met a girl.
Um,
maybe the the night before. Okay.
And the, the girl is like painful.
I know the girl is like 18,
19 in college and this guy is obviously
much older and she wakes up to this
video on her phone. This guy sent her
this video, the next good morning,
Julia. Meet Gel. Just wanted it to say hi.
Wish you a great day.
Tell you that meeting you yesterday and
getting a look at you was probably one
of the greatest moments of my life.
He's in her house.
This guy.
Okay,
we'll do this.
How'd you get a message is hilarious.
This guy just met this girl who was like
20 years younger than I am at least.
And then it was one of those things
where that she probably like,
we're going to find out the details, but
like met at a bar somehow, probably hour.
Everyone was drinking and then he fucking,
instead of texting maybe like nice
meeting you made a video or like where he
like so embarrassed and it goes on
and on and he's like, you'll find love
you like you never been loved before.
You know they'll cherish you. Yeah,
I'll make you look good.
90 Day fiance please me.
But it's like, it's cringy right? You're
like bad. Yeah, it's bad. So anyways,
we got this message today. We've
been playing this, this video.
So a rich Vos. Yeah, that's
hilarious. So somebody said that.
First of all, congrats on the new baby.
My boyfriend and I are longtime listeners.
Living in San Diego is listen
to your mom's house to the day.
Almost spit out the water.
I was drinking when you started to play.
None other than goatee.
Joe's full trato monologue to Julia.
If video during which Jude York
titties man. That's right. Yeah.
That professors his love for his one and
only Julia with multiple shots of his
many ceiling fans in the background.
I've had this exact video saved and
favorited in my phone. Oh my God.
It was sent to Julia the morning after
she and Joe met briefly at a bar when
were city naturally upon receiving it,
Julia sent the video
to everyone she knows,
including my best friend who
I was living with at the time.
I have laughed for hours and hours over
this video as it is quite honestly one
of the most unreal things I've
ever witnessed a grown man do.
After knowing someone for less than 24
hours after getting over the excitement
that my own world just collided
with the world of your mom's house,
I knew what I had to do. There
is a follow up video. Wow.
Surprised after she did not respond to
Joe's initial video. He sent another.
I have attached to it in this email.
He really does seem like a decent guy,
but I do believe the followup video was
a mistake. His on me and beat me Kelsey.
Hey Kelsey, come see me in San Diego.
Added a second. Show the blues.
This is number 24 here's the
real story. Oh Wow. So, okay.
Here's the real story of how they,
the Good Morning Julia is.
Jim requires you to sign your
name before going tanning.
Joe saw her going to sign in.
He then looked at her name when she
went to the tanning room on the way out,
he followed her out, yelling, Julia, wait.
She stopped thinking she may know him.
He then started hitting on her and Julie
explained she was attempting to get
back with her ex show.
Then called himself from her phone and
the next morning he sent the video.
They never dated, never seen each other
since. That ain't no Uber story? No.
Barstow. How did he get her
phone? Yeah, that part does,
that part doesn't really add up, so
that's what somebody's saying. But anyway,
here is the followup video.
Oh Christ.
Just want to say good morning Julia.
I flower.
Oh my precious.
My soon to be my everything.
Have a great day.
Love.
That's it. That's creepy. As
fuck though. I don't like to,
I don't like when people do videos when
they're driving. It's very dangerous.
Very dangerous. That's what
stands out to you. It's not good.
This guy is going to hit me.
Wow.
What do you think? Have you ever done a
video like that when you were younger?
A younger man?
No.
You never do anything super
embarrassing when you're like,
so in La stripper on the way to a Bachelor
Party and I live my company card or a
car that's
really are aligned us. No, we are.
We're just as damaged if not
worst and strippers, man.
Damn noon. Oh fuck your heart
to make in your arm to me.
Let's go full throttle
north Bergen. George, let's
go full throttle. Full travel.
Full sweat.
Yeah.
He's trying to say throttle
throttle. Yeah. Got that full travel
cops or you could
still,
he's talking basically.
He's really, he's really crazy. I mean,
here's the thing. Every guy knows,
every guy has done a mini version of this.
In other words,
you say that you are embarrassed
by, you know, maybe you send a text,
maybe it's something in person,
but the degree to which he went is,
that's the part that's crazy to go
that deep on a video on a video too.
So you're like, oh, they can just watch
this over and over. That's incriminating.
It's like sending your day. It makes me
shiver inside to watch. I'm like dammit.
Because I feel that humiliation,
it's hard for me to watch because I
felt that way for people to, you know,
I've left a voicemail as a comedian,
you're watching the whole thing going
is this whole thing is just bombing.
It's bombing. Exactly. That's
exactly, exactly, yeah.
Still doing it.
That's the common to be doing the same
open 20 years at the Alex Dies House on
Saturdays.
You not shouldn't do it.
And he keeps hitting those videos,
but he'll keep sending them.
Right. So he gets thrown in jail.
I guess probably this is the kind of guy
that would re he would actually use our
love together. I think he's delusional
enough where if she goes, uh,
the thing is I just, um, I'm
just, I don't want to date you.
And he'd be like, he'd
be like, you know what?
It doesn't matter who you are seeing
right now because the love that I have for
you, it's unparalleled. And she would be
like, no, I just don't want to see you.
And he's like, I'll wait
for you. That's sad.
I want to be says one for every holiday.
Merry Christmas. Yo. Full throttle.
I, let me tell you, I'm not looking
for know how get your body, oh,
Christmas as Mother's Day.
He could be my mommy.
He's so fucked up. I mean, thanksgiving,
I've had a few jet. There's,
what's his name? Joey. Yeah.
I've had a few of these guys in college.
This is before the video era.
They don't take no for an answer.
You have to be so explicit
over and over and over.
Like you have to be really like Julia.
She needs to just say no very loudly.
I think these guys ever responded
or have a male friend be like,
if you fucking do this again, I'm going
to break your legs and how you do it.
He doesn't love you the way I love you.
Oh he's, he's real crazy.
He's got, he's got to up.
So let me let, let me wrap this up. Uh,
go see Philippe this weekend
in Houston and Dallas.
Philippe, world.com for
tickets. Phillip, his world.
And he's got Tampa improv coming up.
And you're also adding one other place.
You said the Denver,
I'll paramount theater.
Oh, she took on a podcast. What's up fool?
What's up? Cool. Thanks a
lot for coming brother fools.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
A closing song has come dump and try it
out by sons of dad mouth. All right guys,
we'll see you next week.
Fuck
fuck.
If somebody beat me a home, Ya know, you
see anyone come over today in Florida?
Find
out man, it's in my bill. The drug
out fucking piece. Let me try it out.
You have to apply it on as fuck man.
I'm looking for the hard core guy.
Want to do it and I want to deliver it.
I'm a hot flopped white trash.
Come dump the fuck.
Fuck.
Oh,
you
brought
up
right.
Gotcha.